with watson pylons and then like caustic traps stacked on
there yeah yeah yeah oh hey it's okay gen one yesterday's
twitch rivals i got 19th place ill average out
and don't worry ill average out i was on look i was on the i
was on wigs team okay like tempo what was tempo doing and
tempo i was on wigs team we were we were all of us we were
all not not gonna make it we're not it's gonna average out
we can average our rankings out from here oh my god so it's
looking like a ninth place or what yeah yeah what's the
average it's okay apparently like only placements matter so
we don't have to get any kills we just gotta be first to win
money no we got this we got this yeah the code's up by the
way oh yeah the code's the codes up i'm in it it's all right
we got this we have jen he won last twitch rivals he
practically has the winning streak right now exactly yeah i
want pro league i want twitch rivals exactly if you lose
this game all your achievements never mattered
if you lose this tournament jen then that means those the
other wins they were luck.
They were lucky.
This is where real skill matters now.
Punching and shit?
Like a man.
No weapons is real skill.
It's all about your brain at that point.
It's here to test your brain.
Oh shit, you're fucking right.
Wait, do you have aim assist on punch?
No, no, wait.
He does.
Wait, does do you?
Did he take that out?
No, what?
He got rid of it.
Yeah, I think I'm good.
Why?
He used to be in the game.
Yeah, it was.
You used to be insistent on punching.
Why?
Control-A-Play should have everything they want.
That's so true.
Yeah, might as well.
Give them everything.
Might as well.
They're basically keeping the game alive at this point.
Wait, I can't find the code.
Where is it?
It's in the code section.
It literally says code.
It has a PC icon or a laptop icon.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
Yeah, first game.
What are we playing?
We're playing Fuse.
Clostick Watson.
Fuse Clostick Watson?
Yeah.
Okay.
I can do Watson.
I'll just put fences.
I'll be the fences, girl.
I can do anyone but Fuse because I don't play him.
I don't have him unlocked because I hate him.
I'm not going to unlock.
Wait, you don't have him?
How many tokens do you have?
I do, but I played maybe like two games on Kostik
realistically.
Wait, but just you must have a million.
I have a million legend tokens.
You must have the tokens to unlock.
I don't unlock them.
I just.
Oh, so you don't like money?
Wait, no, no, no.
Spoons, hold up.
Wait, no, no, no, listen, listen.
So you don't like money?
I will call off you if that's what it takes.
I'll do it.
No, no, no, wait, wait.
Spoons.
Is it because he's Australian?
Is he Australian?
Do you hate Australian?
He is Aussie, yeah.
i'm australian too no i took offense cause ain't no way do
it call her that you have the pass does that mean you have
the pass we have to wait but like wait he's like unlocked
right no yeah fuses no it's mad maggie mad maggie is
unlocked this week is everyone are we waiting for someone
can i like unlock him really quick yeah yeah no there's
you're fine there's like two people that's not here okay i'm
just gonna say back really quick oh my god he can't believe
i'm wait he's in rotation though i think really nice like
grenades are allowed right yeah grenades are allowed i'm not
gonna be safe this hurts inventory full of grenades yeah
yeah it's gonna be if we get to end game we're set we're set
all the fences all the names the grenades early by the way
unless we're gonna kill someone yeah yeah yeah unless you
get that stuck okay just get that stuck that that grenade
suck and you'll be fine literally my first time playing fuse
but it's okay i'm really good at sticking arc stars okay
wait do you want to play okay i'll play fuse then you play
clostick no no no um i think it's better if we have a good
costic because fused you're just kind of spam okay but is he
a good i'm gonna say like is he i don't think i've ever seen
like caustic willingly like has he ever played like caustic
willingly he's a controller player hey i want a championship
of caustic i'm just saying yeah yeah that's why you're
playing caustic well like fuse is op you can stick people
and shit like it's fun oh so then you don't want to win if
you why would you justify yeah 46 the clash character all
good sorry we have plenty of time i think we were supposed
to we were supposed to start like seven minutes ago but apex
stuff never starts in time so we're good to go oh yeah yeah
we're good to go
oh okay look at team one please look at team one team four
then team two how are these fair okay yeah because they're
not using guns what the do you mean half of those players
are controller players they don't have brains so what they
don't have brains it's literally melee what are you gonna do
punch you better yeah i mean oh they punch is better or
something i don't know oh yeah when you become a pro player
you punch people better like they add 10 plus more damage if
you get into pro league is that it for each legend yeah but
imagine we survive to end zone like caustic old easy win we
don't even exactly unless they also have unless my watson
all eats it that is true yeah i think we can assume that
every team will have a caustic and watson it's okay it's
okay it's okay we have there's gonna be one team with like a
crypto we have yeah i feel so yeah it has to be but it's
okay we can i can put fences again Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can crypto out me once, but I have infinite fences.
Well, we'll slap all ourselves too.
You're not real.
They're gonna start punching the generator out.
Not if you're not punching them away from the gen.
We play protect the president.
The generator is our president.
It really is.
Wait, get the generators, the two generators.
You know what I want?
Oh, shit, you're right.
You're right.
They can't kill.
They can't kill all the gems.
So what we do at the start of the game, we go run around.
And we just farm fucking armor to purple.
Oh my god, wait, you're right.
And then we'll go to zone.
All right?
You're right, you're right.
You're thinking.
You're actually using your brain for real.
Hey, what brain?
Just tap into Zero's brain right now.
I'm tapping into it.
He's going to get rolled.
Dang it.
He's nervous.
He's so nervous.
He's going to be so scared.
If you beat Zero, you can become IGL.
Really?
Yeah.
rules if you perform better than your igl you become the new
igl in a troll tournament yeah how are you seeing this is a
real tournament this has more money involved than twitch
rivals had how much was it this has more money involved than
twitch rivals how dare you actually yeah this is a hundred k
yeah it's a hundred k prize man i deserve that yeah i won
the game that matters that's the one that matters One game
of this is a half your prize winning from Twitch Ripe.
Oh my god.
Don't you dare tell me this is a troll tournament.
Now you're gonna do it again today.
Just for this match though.
I need to say, hold on.
Just for this game.
And then you can like tone it down.
No, or he could win every game.
Oh wait, no, no, he's gonna be not gonna be on my team.
So just this game.
You can win this game and then fuck off the next other
games.
Yeah.
Wait, is it?
Wait, do we, like, change teammates every time?
Yeah, every game is a different team.
Oh, hell, bye.
Yeah.
So this is the one that matters.
So if you win, you get 1K.
Yeah, we win and we get 1K, exactly.
And we already...
Do we get, like, that $500 entry-free?
I think we do, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
But when you make it to finals, you also get a free $500.
Oh, fuck, yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
So if we win this, that actually is half the Twitch R, your
Twitch R, rivals winning and if you come 11th to 20 if you
still get a hundred bucks yeah you still yeah well this is a
free money farm exactly so it's not troll this is better
than pro league wait this is serious how did this tournament
is better than pro league because it's the finals you don't
understand we worked so hard to get here i worked so hard to
get here see if you get like kill leader in gdms or you have
to get win a game in bl or something yeah you have to either
win a game or become kill leader i mean that's easy yeah
that should be that's really easy right that's so easy yeah
i got this my me and my two bronze badge two bronze and plat
badge i got this we'll be fine wait where are we dropping we
haven't even discussed Wait, where are we landing?
Was it Overlook, I think I saw earlier?
Are we going Overlook?
Wait, do we clean a spot?
I'm pretty sure that's what I saw Jen put, but I could also
be wrong.
Um...
Yeah, yeah, Overlook, I think.
I don't know if we're contested, though.
It's fine.
What are you going to do?
Punch us out?
Right?
Oh, no, we get it by ourselves.
It will be fine.
there's no way there there's no way they get get out
contested yeah how how how do you talk that much you talk
more than me how's it possible being a fucking professional
vtuber that's how i don't think i should sign up for five
seconds you know it's because when you don't have aim you
have to compensate it with other stuff to make people watch
you What's that?
You So I'm professionally up, eh?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got a degree in mission or what?
They're not here to watch me for my aim.
They're here to watch me for relay the vibes.
Yeah, for the vibes and the relay ability.
Because if I can make it in this tournament, anybody can in
your chat.
You hear that chat?
Why are you guys not in here?
You guys suck.
That's right.
No, no, no.
That means you have a chance.
My aim might not be as good as Shen, more money than him
maybe coming for me if i out earned gen in this tournament
in this in this tournament that means you can too so prior
to this i had 500 earning in this tournament yeah 500 yeah
we're all of us do we're we're all okay okay i'm as equal to
gen right now i'm my prize winning is as equal to gen
it'll be fine you know horizon dokey horizon yeah the
british kid yeah you talk more than him i talk more than
this isn't he the spider-man kid yeah the spider-man sounds
like tom holland yeah tom holland
it's a good thing yeah that's good i'm gonna see he's
entertaining it is yeah he already has a friend finally he's
tom holland at walmart
in that wish that seems more like it now i'm gonna tell him
about that yeah he's gonna start crying he's gonna stay
we're landing in overlook yeah we're overlook oh yeah good
yes we can just like start farming armors from them yeah hey
i'm on watson all right i have you selected clay just
unlocked him okay oh my god you scared me where the is watch
oh there he is hey he's like wait
Yeah, we're a champion at Kostik.
So you have Fuse not unlocked, but you have a skin for him.
How does that work?
Yeah, how does that work?
I spent a lot of money on this game.
I'll just say that.
And not Fuse?
Wait, you spent money on a free to play game?
Yeah, I'm living free.
No, because like when there's the heirloom events, like, um,
I'll buy out the events.
So I'll get certain skin.
So you spent money on a free to play game.
So you said...
All right, drop us to victory.
I don't get I don't get how you think that justifies you
spending money on it But it really doesn't like I do not
want to look at my like steam purchase history for this game
I'll actually cry I think mentally.
I'll never be able to recover.
That's okay.
I actually spent money on the Mirage statue Recently like I
was kind of spending money on this game and then recently I
haven't been I've been getting things for free You know
yeah, that's yeah, the destroyer one right 2000 destroyer
packs Yo, that guy homie, for real.
He gave me two and a half for free.
Bro, is he in chat right now?
You want to hack us real quick again?
He saved me $300 from this event.
I was saying.
All right, it's looking.
All right, look, if things don't do so well, maybe he'll
hack your game and you'll be back to life or something.
Okay, I'm going to grab...
We can grab heroes and stuff, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that would be fucked up if we had.
I'm not going to lie.
I grabbed, like, a flatline vault because of everything.
Oh my god.
Wait, can we like grab guns and throw the guns at them to
distract them?
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait, no.
Imagine guns that damage when you throw at them.
Don't think of it this way.
We grab the gun, throw it at them, and then they shoot us,
and then they get disqualified.
I'm just thinking they pick it up.
You might be cooking a little too hard.
You're cooking up too much.
What do you mean?
They're gonna like pick up the gun and then they'll pick up
the gun accidentally because you throw it at them.
us then they get disqualified for using the gun because it
didn't say we can't have it in our inventory i can't it
works i'll bet you that can you have a gun on you though
yeah we won't be using i don't know how if you shoot it like
accidentally it's no fun yeah but if you don't shoot it at a
person it should be fine right okay i'm carrying an
alternator you're gonna You're carrying an alternate.
I'm carrying it.
Why are you gonna throw the gun at a person?
Oh my god, we should throw a gun at a person.
I have a Mozam too.
Oh my god.
Wait, tempo's watching!
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Jump the gun!
It was an accident.
Your tempo, bro, come on.
I didn't know I had that on.
It was just like my brain was automated to loot.
Yeah, he's a controller player.
You should...
Help him.
You think they actually think about what they're doing?
He's literally a controller player.
all right i'm gonna get this juicer someone get this one
here okay okay all right anyone land over here i don't i
don't think so oh my god that's how over there you know we
should have got an octane and had an octane just walk right
around picking up the thinking things but is someone here yo
what's up girl are they going for the thing they should be
going for the armor Okay All right, do we want the revive 50
HP or the the falling stars one?
Oh, oh the falling stars, I think more falling stars.
Okay.
What's one do I get actually following range?
Which one do I get?
Guys, we're doing well.
Look at this shit, bye?
All right guys, guys, we gotta we gotta get the other.
Oh my god, bro.
You gotta go to Olympics Holy fuck.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
All right.
Let's grab this one and then we should find some stuff to
open too.
Oh wait, I ignore.
I can do the ring console.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna split up.
Okay, let's get the juicer and then get the ring console
here.
Open our salt bin.
There's no way I'll get punched out on the ring console.
There's no fucking way.
No, no, no, no.
If they do, I'll just snade them.
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
I'm gonna...
I'll make a ring around the ring console so they can't...
They can't come punch you this way.
They can't punch me out if there's a...
If there's a barrier...
This is it.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my gosh, my brain is cooking up some six shots for this.
We just need tempo to not watch and we'll be fine.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There's people here.
They punched a barrel?
I can't see them.
Let's open.
Whoa.
Oh god.
I just saw that man fucking punch the loop the loop cart
Like out of the sky.
Yeah Bro he was gaming Okay, okay, come all right Jenny.
I'm gonna you wait actually I'm gonna make a ring around the
thing I'm gonna make traps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we got surround ourselves Hit that shit.
Okay, I can hit it too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry.
I'm gonna surround you so they can't But you put me in the
cage bro That's right.
Alright.
We're two armor bins away.
This one's good for this one here?
Yeah, yeah, I'll get that.
Get that one and then I'm gonna get this one here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
Wait.
No, we don't have any support or we can't.
I was gonna say we could craft ourselves if we can't.
We can't craft ourselves.
Oh.
Alright, I'm grabbing the other bin.
need a backpack you can't carry all these nades i only had
two i only have two names wait one team died already wait
how did they we're not doing oh i don't know bro how are you
that if donky say how you that bad it's over jesus oh my god
you know you know who was the 20th place but design died
apparently no way bro that's embarrassing okay i'm just
gonna stand here in the open and look carefully at my
abilities not last officially achieved beat through some
knuckle clip wait i think minus 50 explosive damage i feel
like that's wrong should we get red armor probably i don't
know should we just go ahead as well i mean i feel like zone
doesn't really matter right oh yeah it's just gonna run
around yeah everybody's just running around I feel like no I
think we should be together because I feel like people are
actually gonna because everyone is just gonna oh do you have
any oh it's all okay no wait someone landed behind me oh I
have one you're good you're good you're good but I can I can
pick that up yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna go to I'm gonna hit
the gen right dokey did you put the did you get the two
generators the two yeah I did I did don't worry nice I got
you there's no I I saw a lot of fuses So, thank God we're
Watson.
It's a little scary at endgame.
Oh, it's going to be awful.
I feel like we should get another ring console.
We should get that.
Yeah, ring console.
Oh, should we get this one too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should just get them in the 40.
Just grab everything so we can't red army in the end.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we just...
The moment we hit late game where GG's, it's good to go.
We have, like, Watson for...
brain is working over time you know i think like i mean if
we really if do you know end zones then you know yeah you
have to okay i think there's no way you don't no no no
there's some pros that don't there's that's why no wait wait
what are you trying to say i'm trying to say that you're one
of the pros that do know it i hit the 50 50.
but others why is it because they're
What are you trying to imply?
What do you mean by input?
What do you...
What do you use to play the game?
What do you mean?
I didn't imply anything.
I just said some pros just don't know.
Are you trying to say control players are too stupid to
know?
Yeah, that's true.
I'm not even going to deny it.
Okay.
I put a cage around this one so if anyone wants to do that
ring console, they can.
I'm going to go grab it.
this uh this armor wait there's somebody in here wait i'm
grabbing this juicer okay grabbing that juicer wait okay do
you think i'll be safe if i grab the other armor one i
should leave that one there's people right here on me so oh
yeah yeah don't worry there's no way there's no way i'm
gonna get my chip there oh wait do i have the evax i'll
watch from a distance i do not have no i have a mobile risk.
Because they don't punch people on the evac because they can
just keep taking over and over again.
The sky feeds me.
Let's go ahead.
Oh, let's watch him.
People are fucking...
Are you on top?
Spoons?
No, no, no.
Oh, no, right here.
There's a lot of people fighting here right now.
Okay, wait, Jin.
What's endgame?
Endgame is literally on us.
Oh, it is?
Okay, I'm gonna head over to you.
It's fine.
You'll be fine.
Just run.
Oh, I'm up here.
I'm good.
I'm good, I'm good.
Just run.
I'm heading to Jin.
I can't take the balloon to you guys.
Wait, I'm literally right with you.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna peel some shit.
Wait, right here.
They're fucking coming!
No, they're not.
They're too free!
They're like on you!
There's no, no, no.
Don't look back.
If you don't look back, you're not there.
Right.
They're actually gonna punch us.
Wait, no way.
Yo, peace of world.
What are they doing?
They're wasting names.
Play this corner.
Okay.
What the fuck are they doing?
They're wasting good, valuable names.
It's fine.
They're dumb.
Yeah, they're so dumb.
I know.
Keep doing it.
guys definitely control yeah yeah run yeah fucking run we
didn't waste our nades we have a fuse for that okay look i
made us a little ring all right nice i have uh i think nine
i have two i didn't loot that much i i just realized i did i
might not have loot us much as i wanted just keep breaking
the fences spoons and yeah yeah yeah yeah i do just don't
have that gen up yet you want a generator no i couldn't tell
they have no they do they don't they this team has a gen
he's just sitting there which team yeah they do everybody
has a gen i'm not gonna waste my gen because no one's
throwing names at us actually maybe i should actually they
can't get rid of this I have two pylons too He's looking oh
my god.
I'm pull down on my thing.
What's up, bruh?
Wait, this is our space get out Wait, how much more how many
more fences?
I have two more fences.
You can pull a 12 down.
How many?
I broke their fence two more Like that.
I'm just gonna make it longer Don't worry.
It's fine But look at their baby cage we have so much space
here.
Yeah, literally.
Like, look at our space.
Get shit on.
Yeah, waste your gen.
Because they're setting it really far from their gen.
People are playing Newcastle.
That's troll.
I guess, oh, like, I think for Endgame.
That's really good for Endgame.
Well, Newcastle's not going to save them from costing gas.
That's true.
Have these guys seen any Gibbies yet?
I don't think I've seen a Gibby.
Me neither.
I haven't seen a Crypto yet, either, honestly.
Who's is good because you can hold, like, two grenades per
slot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, wait they took away my space I'm gonna
steal their fences here.
Okay.
I can break that in five seconds.
Wait.
I saw one of them Okay, I connected to mine Do I dare you to
put a fence down?
Yeah, if I can do it cow.
Oh, come on.
Come on What the fuck are you doing?
What are you doing?
Wait, they're kind of reinforcements That's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
Yeah out that's working right leave i have needs to leave no
i want to move away
wait how do i we break their fences here so i can take their
fence actually no no don't break it oh oh god okay don't
worry don't worry don't worry i have a I have a need leave
leave don't make me throw this need don't make me oh you
guys I'll do it don't make me oh my god that taps wait did
you throw in the oh no that's your canister we're further
ahead you're gonna chuck it wait how far can you chuck them
oh nice oh my god which side though I don't know which side
This side or this side?
It's probably our side.
Oh my god.
Okay, as long as...
We're in a perfect spot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're okay.
This team has to move forward to us then.
Oh, he's not coming again!
This team has to move to us.
What?
Red!
I've never... We should try farming to red, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, we should.
We should.
I have a thousand.
He's trying to stick me, bro.
What the fuck?
Bro, what is he gonna do?
Look after he sticks me.
If they stick you, I will literally ult you guys.
Okay.
Don't worry.
And then you'll have to fight to death in the Ring of Fire.
No!
Wait, that's smart.
We can spawn in an unlimited arc stars, by the way.
Do you have the perk?
Yeah, yeah, I have the spawn arc stars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, this should do it.
But I can't do it for myself.
I don't- it didn't spawn any yet.
It's because we haven't thrown anything out, or done yet.
Oh!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I- can I do this?
Wait, wait.
What if I- Do it, do it.
Wait, they're rotating, they're rotating, they're rotating!
They're like, cowards.
They're cowards!
Yeah, I'm gonna punch the gen.
Wait, did they spawn the knockstop?
They do it against me?
Wait, they don't know!
I don't know where they're falling.
Okay, they patched it.
I patched it.
Wait, did it?
I mean, the enemy has to do it, yeah.
Wait, wait, they took over.
They took over the area.
Okay, I'll break the fence again in seven seconds.
Can't believe it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna pick up this and then...
them here.
You're gonna cage them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna cage them here.
They're in my gas!
They're gas in the gas thing!
Oh my god, nice.
Nice.
Yeah, that's right.
I can put one good grenade on that.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's people in here.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Okay, never mind.
I'm gonna, you're not caged anymore.
Those weirdos.
I'm gonna put- Oh, they put another gen there too.
I'm gonna put a fence here.
All right.
A loba.
Oh, what the fuck are you gonna do lovo there's no loot here
nobody's dead there's literally 19 squads a brain dead thing
what are you gonna get wait is one team a rat no question
mark oh no someone just died i don't i can't do i can't do
math oh we can play we can play start setting up here come
here okay don't worry i got you wait i'm gonna grab these
fences on this rock yeah yeah quick quick quick okay
extending oh someone on you whoa don't worry oh we're fine
i'm putting as many fences as possible they're in my face
they're in my fences they're in my fire oh my god they're
still they're trying to punch you wait they can even suck in
that oh they're punching the button you're punching the
offenses it's okay we're fine i'm punching the phrase but
you're crazy you're fucking crazy
there we go don't worry i connected everything traps down
bro what the is wrong with you
it's okay there's someone else balkery right here it's okay
we still they can't come in they can't come in here they're
still trying to my fences but I'm just putting him back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Fuck you, Korsi!
Yeah, fuck up!
Looky bitch!
Wait, Korsi, try to break you, try to break all!
It's okay, it's okay, we're fine, we're fine.
I still have my fences, we're fine!
What's about these mobis?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Okay, we don't have fences in our backs anymore, by the way.
I got lots of them.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh my god, I was gonna stick one.
Oh my god, they're still fucking fencing it up.
Okay, jump down, jump down!
We can play on me too.
Maybe start fencing this side.
Come, come, come, come.
Okay, okay, okay.
Right here, right here.
Fuck those guys, I don't like them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, those guys are weirdos.
They have a devil?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't.
I don't.
Okay.
We gotta protect the gen then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we got protected.
They're throwing naves and stuff on our gen.
We're five.
I'm 62 per- I have- I have all the stealth.
I can use it.
I can end turn ends here.
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I can put a gen down.
I have a gen, I have a gen.
I have a gen.
We can put gen here.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
Yeah, and then Alt-Xel for the next one.
Alright, here.
I already use my Alt-Xel for this gen.
Yeah, yeah.
Unless you guys have, uh...
I don't have any.
I'll give you a spin.
I'll try and break some stuff over here.
It's okay.
I have a ring.
We're gonna have to start breaking fences soon.
I'm breaking.
Hold up.
Yeah, okay.
Bro.
This team is still here.
Oh, is it?
Okay, we have.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
We gotta keep breaking their fences.
We have...
Oh, my God.
Do not worry.
Oh, no.
Whoa, they're trying to...
They're trying to fight, yo.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're good.
On the left.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're fine.
They're breaking the fences for us.
They're breaking it for us.
They're clearing the path.
We're actually chilling.
Yeah, they cleared the path.
They cleared the path.
We just need them to clear.
Yeah, look, look.
They're clearing the path.
We're doing good on my ping.
All right.
This is gonna be hell.
This is actually gonna be a death.
We can't use them.
I'm good.
All right.
We have to move up soon.
We have to put a generator.
I don't have it.
I already used it.
Yeah, I already used it for our other gen When did you get
it?
When did you get new one?
Oh far We use their gens.
They have gens that we can use It'll be fine.
We use their generators.
We can't name anyone So fine.
We can't just hold the way.
Push this condo out.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, that's my defenses We got this.
No one's in our side by hold up.
Yes, we have to start the gate.
Hachifei da zone.
The fuse.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
No way.
I'm not even old, man.
Go on the campback.
Wait, the campback, baby.
The campback.
I'm going on the campback.
I'm on the campback.
Okay.
Guys.
I'm not doing so well, guys.
I am.
Not okay.
I'm not okay.
I'm fucking chatting the campback.
Look at me, guys.
I'm fucking ed.
Oh my shit.
Dude, campback is very good.
Oh my god.
Yes, it is hell.
Wait, wait, put the shield.
I'll use my shield.
I don't know which one you guys are.
Do you feel the shield?
That's me, that's me, that's me.
Oh my god.
You good, like, Ducky, you good, you good?
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
I don't feel good.
Bro, what the fuck?
I don't feel so good.
Bro, I got knocked out.
Jet, this is up to you.
What the fuck is going on?
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
I can't move.
I can't move my god.
I
know what the fuck.
Oh my god.
I'm getting placement.
Six.
Yeah, I could have won.
Who won?
Bro, what the fuck?
That was fucking insane.
Where was the crypto when we needed it?
I couldn't move.
Nobody picked crypto.
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ Oh my god, it's actually crazy
No, I got blocked by 20 people in front of me
Nice nice that yeah, no one crypto for real no one went
crypto.
So there was just offenses everywhere Where?
Oh my, the Newcastle won!
Holy fuck!
Newcastle won, dude.
The Newcastle won's the play!
Who would have died?
Oh my god, Newcastle and Valkyrie, dang.
Oh my god, what even happened?
Yo, we left 400 bucks off that though.
Fucking take it!
Oh, let's go!
Wait, wait, how much did we win?
400.
400?
Easy.
Okay, now for the rest of the game, just throw it.
yeah yeah yeah now you don't have to try anymore yeah yeah
yeah you're already up that money you already got the 400
you can just relax now yeah like you know maybe like try mnk
out for a bit bro you can't say that he's actually good at
mouse and keyboard is he yeah i try to play with your
monitor off i'm actually master's level yeah he went like i
watched i watched your fucking what was it one stream uh 41
hour stream yeah yeah the one where you fucking went crazy
the longer it went and the one okay yeah the bronzer thing
the one where you just started talking to yourself at one
point because you were what when did I do that you did you
were starting to talk to yourself in that stream and I was
like this man's not okay I was 41 hours deep what he meant
you were not okay I did a 48 hour before that too and I was
talking to myself Mandy got a haircut and then I literally
saw her on stream live that day and I looked to my wall
right I could see him I could picture like it's like you
could see him I could see him yeah he's like right next to
me type shit you mean Mandy is your fucking like sleep
paralysis demon or some shit my girlfriend is my girlfriend
damn all right teams are out I think we got wait oh we're on
the same team again spoons for real yeah oh yeah oh dang
yeah yeah so we're replacing you with timmy wait i don't i
think you got replaced with timmy that three strikes no
lifeline all right good luck i guess yeah good luck good
luck bye all right team 20 all right let me going to team 20
now me too all right we got this that was just hello hello
hello how did your team do timmy we got 12.
whoa were you in that cluster were you um we got we were
climbing a rock and someone kamikaze me into the zone and my
face and i spawned in and i instant died i was like oh my
god okay that's good the end game you didn't want to be in
that mosh pit that shit was that mosh pit was fucked up and
never felt so useless i was like i'm used here standing with
like a bag full of nades can't even use them all the fact
that there was no crypto nobody actually picked the crypto
was very surprising at least got to play crypto everyone was
like i know the other team is gonna play crypto everyone was
like watson caustic fuse and then the of course the
newcastle team won mm-hmm that's pretty shocking wait okay
newcastle is the move yeah but and the thing is the next one
is uh three strikes and it doesn't say no newcastle just no
lifeline it also says it doesn't say no mirage why the okay
okay i was gonna say why the fuck would you play mirage but
Wait, wait, wait, I want to do Mirage.
Wait, I want to be Mirage.
Yeah, go for it.
Go for it.
Okay, I need people to leave Team 20 so we can join Team 20.
Um, so I also, unfortunately, cannot play Newcastle.
I could try.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What should we do for Compton?
Well, I can play Newcastle if you want to play Mirage.
I'm down for that, too.
Yeah, yeah, because I've, like, you know, you know, I played
Newcastle in Lifeline in Three Strikes because I'm that
fucked up as a person.
Oh, no, no, I definitely played Lifeline in Three Strikes.
Whatever it takes.
Whatever it takes to win, you know, pubs are that important
for the regular person.
We don't have much.
Yeah, honestly, I haven't played Three Strikes in a while.
So, I mean, I know that obviously the comp is Lifeline,
Newcastle.
Yeah, but we can't have Lifeline.
Yeah, so I think Newcastle, I do think people are probably
going to play Conduit as well.
Yeah, true.
Conduit's really good.
I can also play Conduit.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's probably like a Newcastle Conduit, and I don't
really know what that last one would be.
I think like Mirage, because imagine someone gets downed,
you can just crawl forever until you find your little
Mirage.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter because people don't die anyway,
so when you're down.
Yeah, and then you get a little stealth res off.
what i was thinking is i don't know if it actually works but
um if we play lifeline i think lifeline we can't play oh
wait i'm sorry i'm actually i holy wait did you get sleep
did you get i'm bricked up right in my head right now jesus
christ are you okay what happened you get trauma dumped here
i got a big dent in my head right now oh
All right, all right, so what's... What are you cooking to
me?
What are you cooking?
I lost all cookage after that.
Give me a second.
Okay, after, after, like, Spoons and I was like, you know,
there's still a lifeline three times in a row.
You guys were saying it too many times that I thought, like,
honestly, yeah, it's been a lifeline.
Yeah, you know what?
What is Tempo gonna do?
Kick me out of Skrims?
He wouldn't.
Yeah, he would never do that to you.
you out of every tournament he organizes.
All right.
What...
I don't really know.
I'm not gonna lie, because we can play...
We could play save if you want to play save.
We could also play like somewhat aggro and such rotate, or
we could just play full aggro.
That's like kind of the three options.
Well, the thing is that Tempo set kills don't matter.
It's all about placement.
is going to be playing for placement which is why we had
like 18 squads at like round five or something last match
yeah so i think if we play too aggressively we'll just die
also there's like some fucked up teams too like there's some
like team four team four there's team four there's team four
there's team five there's i don't know how aggressive we can
play guys guys team a with omu and sniped down uh the thing
about when when i played this um and the like there's a
journey back then is it was i think before the evo system
was changed but we pretty much want to get red armors before
we get to end game because if we we pretty much don't have
loot you know what i mean like we don't have loot and then
and then we go into the final we're most likely not going to
win so we pretty much need triple red armor or roughly
purple armors and a of meds and needs and i don't know how
much we're going to get realistically from our off drop wait
what where are we landing what's our drop point that's a
great question i think we go north pad that's okay they will
never bully you out of your drop spot you're timmy yeah yeah
right yeah they would never they see your name they're like
we can't contest them it's timmy yeah all right we're gonna
go north pad it's gonna be an edge type of um oh yeah okay
POI.
We should roughly get purples by the time we leave.
I think honestly I'm probably shouldn't have played Ray.
It would be easy.
And then just do the Newcastle and what was it?
Conduit.
Conduit?
Okay.
Newcastle, Conduit.
Because Conduit's really good for endgame when there's a lot
of teams.
So you have that Conduit ult.
Newcastle will res us.
I could port us back or port us into positions because
people are going to play zone and they're going to be like a
bunch of crazy spots so if I can just port us into a spot
and then we Newcastle Olds, we should be fine Alright,
alright I'll be Newcastle And I'm down to Conduit Cool Yeah,
look at that Look at your cooking You know, I believe in us
I see the vision Yeah, I see Timmy's vision right there
Yeah, yeah, I will let you know There is going to be a lot
of revenant conduits Running around if you see a revenant i
think it's best to us for for us to turn around but in
general it's hard to kill uh a revenant conduit anyways and
ranked but yeah i do think they're the i feel like jen
burton is going to be on revenant and he will kill us all
it's okay that's why we have two more choices we have two
more true we have two more strikes and then we we know where
he is so we fly away from there exactly the opposite side of
the yeah yeah then we'll be fine we'll be fine we're we're
like we're peaceful um like what are they gonna do kill us
as long as one of us is standing they can't so we'll be fine
yeah there's no way in apex legends all right new castle uh
where the fuck is the hover oh we can craft oh wait we don't
we yeah no we can't craft you guys never die forever Never
mind.
You're kicking too hard.
Guys, I thought too hard.
We can play Lifeline.
Pick a Lifeline.
Yeah, we're picking Lifeline.
Go do it!
No, but you said that.
I was actually going to be like, oh my god, it's like
Lifeline.
But it will be...
Don't worry.
Tempo likes me, so he'll restart the game for me.
Easy.
It'll be easy.
If I accidentally...
Honestly, can he just tell us the zone?
Because he can see the zone.
Oh, it's true.
Let me message Tempo real quick.
I'll tell him I'm never let me blackmail tempo real quick
we're jumping we might be contested oh whoa you tell him to
end right now you didn't do one point I told you you had
that much power I have that much power I told him to end the
game look at that he actually did it I did this smile I
didn't in the presence of greatness he knew i have that much
power do we have hot drop or no uh i don't not that no no we
didn't oh wait apparently apparently reps oh wait was it
reps or oh for holes no it was for holes yeah for holes with
hot fucking lifeline oh my god that could have been that
could have been us Are we the only team that are playing?
Why are there so many caustics?
Okay, people are playing caustic.
That makes me want to change my mind.
Do we still want conduit?
No, no, they're playing our comp.
They're just swapping our wraith for a caustic.
Which, honestly, I will probably just change to it.
You're going to conform?
No, actually, now you're right.
Let those...
Actually, you're right.
You're right.
We're going to be a team.
with the right player.
Why did I almost falter?
I know.
I can't believe you're going to be a meta slave.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't believe it.
What happened to you?
You've changed.
I almost changed right there.
Probably changed you.
The peer pressure was actually very crazy.
You wouldn't let meta help decide what you play.
We're here to craft.
We're here to theory craft, not be the sheep.
There were the wild cards.
We're about to win this.
Yeah, exactly.
Wild cards always win.
That's why we're wild.
Are you guys, uh, question, are you MNK or Roller?
MNK.
We're the MNK squad.
We're so fucked.
Oh, God, that's fucking good.
Wait, wait, we're fucked.
Wait, what are you talking about?
MNK is up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Long range.
Long range fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, now we can actually use our guns, so it's fine.
It's okay.
I'll contact Destroyer 2009.
We can get some aim assists.
Oh, shit, you're right.
You're right.
table give us walls as well with the extra 50 all right
we're looking okay we're looking good all right you guys can
land at the over here probably spit off me yeah yeah i'm
gonna loot over here i'm like building middle here yeah just
be careful because when people die they can always like land
on you i think the closest thing is checkpoint maybe i'll
get that i don't know i don't know how the respawns work but
uh there's a chance that people just don't know you're there
and then they just land on you yeah i mean we just look up
if they yeah oh my god someone already got knocked all right
i'll go on the right side oh my god it feels weird grabbing
guns it feels like i'm doing something it's not loud oh yeah
we're run nemi r9 oh no there's a carbide here
Do we need evil?
There's an evil here.
We want to grab that.
Yeah.
We will grab that.
Because we are little...
We're in our whities.
Can we know if you guys find any marksman weapons?
We'll have to grab them.
The blue heavy mag.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I'll loot the house in front.
Wait, did you loot the...
Oh, you loot it at the far right.
Okay.
I'm gonna loot the house.
wait does the design died again is he 20 no he's not 20 a
place at least no teams in white there's a purple bag here
oh let's see i haven't played newcast in a while should i
get the swift shield or the thick shield um can you read
them to me uh mobile shield gains 250 hp increase mobile
shield speed to weapon sprint uh probably the hp one all
right there's a blue bag here oh we all have blue bags we're
fine fine we're healthy there's a purple mag
and then for your can you read me the other one as well
what's your level two oh uh my level three is 250 castle
wall hp or allies revive with health regen up to 75 um the
first one we already regen when you or like does it regen on
top of that too no no no it's just an instant hp so we just
want we we res with what's it called 100 every single time
so there's no point in getting the second one okay yeah all
right so the stronghold right the castle wall ap right yeah
yeah because i read it out of order so i was like And then
for your conduit one, can you read your conduit abilities?
Oh, I do the 10% jammer, and then I usually do the gain and
extra tackle charge instead of the range.
See, I'm trying to think.
Yeah, let's see that.
Right.
Yeah, I'm not too sure, honestly.
I think that one's just good because it, like you get it so
often.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
we should grab the harvesters yeah we both um we should do
the prowlers right now so we can get uh potentially close to
purple all right let's go i'm here you
where's the other prowlers nobody's gonna be out shoot it oh
this one's so far away oh is the shooting the prowlers thing
a myth or is it actually true wait a minute was that
somebody landing you back for yes you shooting it does
actually do something okay that's not a myth it's real after
a certain amount of time you shoot it and then it's kind of
just making noise
i knew it was real no it touched me i dropped a 2x if anyone
wants it i am 11.
let's see actually i'll probably take that
Is there any extra light ammo?
I can go up your stack.
It's fine.
I have like, I have a hundred right now.
I'm just curious.
Okay.
Let's go!
We'll be fine.
I'll shoot this down.
This flyer that we're driving to.
Yeah.
He's almost dead.
It's dead.
Oh, it's purple.
We'll grab it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Phoenix shit.
Oh, do you grab it?
You got it?
Yeah, I did it.
Oh, I grabbed it.
I grabbed it.
Sorry, I'm bad at driving.
That's why our pro player will drive for us.
Yes, yes.
I got you.
Can you grab this?
Yeah, I'll grab it.
Okay.
Yay.
Um, we are going to grab this one and then we craft a med
kit there.
Great.
All right.
here no no uh the zone the zone drops them yeah yeah the
zone the zone hits uh pv oh the guy is here there yeah we
fight the fight the fight the okay okay okay i can i can i
can one all right i'm going in boom okay i'm right behind
them what's in what's in low what's in there nice let's go
okay look at us wait i'm looking up i'm looking up just in
case just in case they're gonna come back They're angry.
They're so angry.
I'm looking up.
No, they're not.
They're not.
They don't want to fly in the zone.
They're way too stupid for that.
Okay.
They don't want the smoke.
Yeah, yeah.
I got two mech kits for you guys.
If any of you guys need batteries.
I got bad.
I crafted a bat too.
I should be good.
I'm just going to grab an extra bat just in case.
Oh, my God.
So many bats.
Can someone hold this up just now?
The other one?
I'm holding one already.
What?
Could actually someone swap me a purple bag?
Wait, I can hold this actually.
I can hold it.
I have a purple bag.
Yeah, can someone swap me?
Because I'll probably be looting a lot of the boxes for us.
I don't know how efficiently swap so everything's just gonna
spill out.
Yeah, that's fine.
Good.
I'm gonna make another med kit for us.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can get into the car.
All right.
Just gonna...
make sure i have everything i need all right let's go oh
wait wait i'm driving the car whoa whoa what happened spoons
actually i didn't even oh okay i guess it was better than i
hit this we can we can die the zone by the way yeah if you
if you yeah yeah i forgot wait how many seconds do we have
in zones again uh five we have five minutes five minutes oh
goal what a noob what's your team yeah it was a dsg yo yo yo
yo yo whoa i'm gonna dead his own real quick so i can okay i
see i see the vision that's smart okay don't worry anytime
now yeah i'm looking at that timer a little scared okay i
was also seeing the rest timer
We'll go here.
There's a lot of people, well, there's a team over there
that just...
I'm gonna scan the...
I was gonna see how I fell down.
I'm gonna grab the armor here.
Got it?
Yep.
Perfect.
Let's go up here.
Alright.
Just a nice scenic ride.
I hope we get out of the door.
20 teams.
so oh no i'm stuck in the car i am what is going on oh my
god i don't know what's going on oh my god where are you go
just run just run thank you yeah i recently i rest i rest
but i got hit i got hit hold your knock hold your knock
emily i'm holding a psychs oh they came out of nowhere i got
stuck in that car in the horizon old they're ranting it
they're not shameless shameless i can't believe it uh we can
land on the creeper it's okay we have all our stuff but
they're also super stacked now okay maybe not on the creeper
so i'll just look at um let's land our perfect rotate
purpose so we can get a spot right yeah yeah this may not be
the right spot to go but let's go here there's a team right
here yeah i landed at the bottom whoops okay that's fine i'm
safe here i think yep um um are you guys safe up there
though um i think we're gonna drop down drop down drop down
Yeah, let's go near.
Lay in here.
Fine.
I have ult in 50.
Yep.
Here's an extra mid kit.
There's a Phoenix kit right here.
If anyone wants it.
Be okay.
It actually pulled across, so let's follow me.
Hey.
Yeah, we're gonna pray that this team does not hold this
out.
Oh.
But they have blue armor.
Yeah, we're going to play.
One has purple.
Okay.
All right, we're going to play out here.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
I don't see anybody behind that team.
Yeah, we're going to fight at this building.
Right.
I have all these.
Yeah, we can hide.
There's another team going northwest.
and they're gonna they're gonna fight them first okay kind
of just wait that's good all right so we just hide we don't
make presents yeah yeah yeah i'll take this rock so you
can't get us all yeah i have all two we need it i'll have i
have pd2 right now oh this is a canon ending especially
probably over here wait i have evac you ever need to use it
yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna put go for these buildings
and then we'll evac over into okay spot my guy is still 20
swaths oh no and zone is gonna be hell all right follow me
all right behind you i don't shoot him don't shoot him okay
keep walking hug the wall blow walk up yeah over here i
think they might have saw us but
We're little rats.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rats.
Okay.
Walk up.
I'm here.
We are hard chilling here.
We're gonna sit right here.
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
No one will ever know.
Oh, nice.
No one will.
Be careful the window behind you.
Yeah.
Just hide in the corner.
Hello.
I'll be in this corner.
Perfect, perfect.
How far are you guys from your red?
I had 759.
Okay.
Oh my god, a squad full died.
I think we climb up.
We're not 20th.
Yeah, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
We can look for this.
Okay.
Did they die?
They might have died.
Yeah, they might have died.
Ring closed in one minute.
Let us see.
he's looking back at us does he know does he know our
existence i don't think he knows i don't think he knows
we're pretty much gonna follow behind them okay all right
and they and they clear the way for us yeah i should be fine
you too nothing to worry about oh yeah we'll be hard we'll
be so chill yeah what are you gonna do turn around this
guy's looting looting the boss until there's literally
nothing in it.
What is he gonna do?
Just fucking stay there forever until the zone kills him.
Don't turn around.
Okay.
Follow my path thing.
Try not to hit the traps.
I'm okay.
We're gonna go and lean to the right here a little bit.
You ready to 3-2-1 this person in front of us?
Yeah.
They're right here.
Ready?
Go!
Got him!
Last one?
Classic.
Nice.
Really good job.
Yep.
Stay right here on me.
Okay.
Yeah, there's a team with the Newcastle wall.
I have all two.
We need to use it.
I need Newcastle right in the zone right here at this rock.
Okay.
I'm doing it.
Yep.
And then we play the wall.
We play the wall.
Okay.
Shoot them.
Shoot them in front of us.
They all died.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey, see there.
I'll try, right?
Wait, they did all die.
Oh, they all died?
Okay, do we take that spot?
I know, you say that, you say that.
Okay, stay there.
You want to watch the right- There's a team on my team too.
Yeah, watch the right side.
Watch the right side.
They're rotating.
Blue armor, blue armor.
Yeah.
Blue armor on this team.
You can't be coronated forever.
I might need Andrew Yammer.
Is there Andrew Yammer over there?
To me?
Uh, yes, there is.
Okay, Jared, come to you or you taxi it over?
Uh, you will come to me in a second.
I'm gonna make sure that...
Oh, okay, team right up here, too.
I'm going in, I'm going in, I'm going in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can come over here.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, might be on us.
Oh, shit.
This will stay back for...
We're real fine.
We have this...
You guys want to...
Yeah, start shooting, start shooting so you guys can get
red.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my God, I got stuck.
Bro, I'm missing my scout shots.
I'm just gonna grab, see if there's any other loot for me.
Oh, here, got red.
Nice.
oh we okay we're gonna we're gonna rotate here we're gonna
rotate here really slow okay i'm looking i am like i'm 100
away from red but i don't have anybody shoot at right now
okay cool you went behind this rock oh this team here too
oh let me shoot you oh i need to grab some light ammo and
walk over to you guys yeah yeah there's a lot I don't think
there's light.
You're going to have to most likely...
There is.
Here, here, here, here.
There's an armor swap in the back if you want to grab the
armor.
Thank you.
Got it.
I'm 3% off from...
Maybe to our right is Eva.
From...
Oh, shit.
Turn right, right.
Can you come here?
Yeah.
Let me know if I need a conduit or anything.
Can you conduit with this up here?
Up here?
We're going to take the zip.
We're going to take the zip and go up.
Okay.
Yep.
Nice.
Do you just shoot that Cossack out?
Take the deck, take the deck, take the deck.
Okay, okay, okay, I'm taking it.
And then you're gonna ult right here, ult right here,
underneath the stairs, underneath the stairs.
All right.
Right underneath, right underneath.
Yeah, right here is good.
Yeah, perfect, perfect.
All right.
They're gonna have damage red on top of.
Yeah, yeah.
They have a Cossack, they have a Cossack, so we have to
shoot the traps.
All right.
We can also play, we can also play in here.
This is really safe.
I nearly need like 45 left for it.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it was a Mirage.
clone.
We can also play right here.
I am.
Wait, wait.
What the fuck?
The windows can see you.
That way we're probably under the stairs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got rid.
I don't need to worry now.
Nice.
20 seconds on my alt.
I mean, on my shields.
Come to me.
Not yet.
I'm getting ticked by the caustic alt.
Yeah, I'm dead.
The caustic alt down to you.
That's okay.
I could just crawl up to you.
There's a prisoner!
Prisoner!
He's trying to beat me off of the...
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Okay.
I'm rising you.
I'm watching.
Yeah, yeah, come back up.
Come back up.
Okay.
We'll play right here.
We're super safe.
All right, here we go.
Do you have your old back?
Here, get your old back.
52.
All right.
Oh, whoa, it's final zone.
I have another alt-excel too, if anyone wants it.
Or do you have portal?
Yeah, I do have portal.
Yeah, I'm popping dogs, huh?
Okay.
What you're gonna do is I'm gonna pour spoons.
I'm gonna pour spoons.
What you're gonna do is you need an ult, okay?
You're gonna ult.
You're gonna ult right here, okay?
Do I- where do I face?
Like, do I face this direction?
Can I face west?
No, no, no, no.
So, so ult right here and then face towards the building.
Towards the building?
Okay, okay.
The building to our right, yeah.
So you're gonna ult right here.
Actually, let me ping you a little bit better.
More right here, right here.
Okay.
right there is the winning spot right so you can see where
i'm standing you oh yeah and then i face the build the the
barrier faces the building okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
want me to take portal with you right away yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right here
that's where you're gonna that's where you're gonna and then
when you when you're old place on your shield as well after
your queue i'll ping it again for you so you understand uh
so you know exactly where i feel like i'm gonna accidentally
go into the portal no no you're good you're good you're good
uh just stand on stand on this and then if you need jump off
you'll be fine okay all right i'm going now okay all the way
here where i am standing all the way around okay ready yep i
know i know right now right now and then turn for the thing
perfect perfect put your shield down put your q put your q
should i ult you put your q put your q down put your q down
oh god i see our armor thing is god no i got it i got you
that's okay put your q down put your q down put your shield
down put your shield shield shield your cue there you are
okay i have to go up to go up i couldn't i have to go up oh
my god oh i'm gonna try to break the caustic traps oh nice
oh dang they broke that caustic i mean oh my god we got fit
we got fit let's go you said my shield okay when you said
shield i thought you made conduit shield that's why i got so
confused I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
I was like, why are you giving us the Q?
Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, I could have ported us in the spot that I went to,
but I feel like we might have died there.
I think our spot was maybe better.
Yeah, I think it was a good spot.
It was a good spot.
Yeah.
That was hard.
I was like, shield?
You mean conduit shield?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
a cue and then i was like shield and i was like it's still
not coming down i didn't say anything yeah i was just like
when's the conduit shield i was good we got fifth we got
fifth that's really good we also got five kills yeah kills
don't matter though i think we should get a hundred for
every kill kill matters in our hearts oh it's duo's time
next round
I think that's like four hundred dollars right still I don't
remember how the prize rings are done um whoa wait a
thousand two hundred wait do each of us get a thousand two
hundred it's split between three oh okay I was gonna say
that's a total 400 bones nice we're so close to five hundred
god damn it how this guy this guy just can't let us win
content creator trainees either like all good dang what's up
with that it's just greedy it's all good all right god damn
stop joining tournament you have enough money all right ggs
guys all right ggs good luck in your next Good luck, good
luck.
Likewise.
Thank you for playing.
Bye-bye.
Alright, there's no Team 22 voice chat, so I'm waiting.
I can't believe the shield was me.
I was so confused.
I was just like, what do you mean?
I was just like, where's the conduit shield?
Where's the conduit?
I was like, don't worry, guys.
I'm here!
I was so...
I didn't realize it was...
I didn't realize it was my shield.
I got confused because Conduit also uses shield.
The shield...
It's just a tomato brain moment.
I was so...
Here we go, don't worry, I'm here.
I was like, yay, I got my all down.
And then I was like, all right, I did my job.
The shields, what do they mean?
The shields.
What do the shields mean?
That's my streamer.
That's me!
I'm so fucking smart.
Alright, I need to look, read it up.
Read up the thing.
What do we need?
Oh, we got new code.
Okay.
New code time.
New code.
My duo is dropped, by the way.
Drop would be my duo.
Which one you two?
Oh, there it is.
That's my duo.
I'm going to see if like any specific rules that it always
it's like a circle it's a circle oh my god he can IGL that's
true I'm already a step up it comes full circle
alright let's see there's no additional rule oh Gibby Costic
only okay okay that's fine we can make this work it's only
Gibby and Costic it's not a circle it's a spiral it was
funny i was so i can't believe i thought it was a khanian
cube i can't believe it i was just like where is my cube
where is it what do you mean i was like god damn it spoons
where the fuck is my khanian cube
It's gonna haunt me for the rest of my life Hey, I still got
top five I still got top five It's still something Chat We
still, Q is in our heart
No, the thing is conduit also does shields That's why I got
confused I thought I was like That's a weird place That's I
was like, that's a weird plan like put down my all and then
a conic queue.
I was like, that's weird because he's like QQQ.
I was like conic queue
Everything was in the heat of the moment He never said which
queue yeah, that's true You know look I need my hand to be
held for IGLing.
Okay, like they have to be very fucking specific or i would
be very fucking confused for the rest of my time like i need
people to be extremely specific in what they mean that's why
okay guys it's not my fault chat it's not my fault they have
to be incredibly specific people need to like people need to
make sure they illiterate uh what is it they have i'm
illiterate but so but people people need to be very very
specific
all right we're just waiting for it we're just waiting for
it dropped and then we should be good to go we're waiting
for it drop to join in it's yeah yeah my streamer moment
look guys i'm the content creator here okay You can't assume
that my brain would be fine-tuned the same way as all the
other actual Apex player.
I'm a content creator.
This is my duo.
Dropped.
That's him.
So, like, it's not my fault.
The content creator debuff chat.
it was sadly the content creator debuff it's a yeah these
are really stacked players yeah I mean the first game we got
Jen second game we got Timmy third game we got dropped
that's actually really lucky for us wait he's not here wait
what do I play he's not he's not even in voice chat what do
I play I don't know We're starting
He's AFK Wait, he plays Gibby, he's known for Gibby, right?
He's known for Gibby, right?
Yo, what do you want to play?
Oh shit, okay, I'm cost, we're here Okay, all right Where
the fuck were you?
We didn't even strategize I had to grab food You grabbed
food?
Was it worth it?
Yeah.
Was it worth it yet?
I haven't yet.
have an eight what do you get though i got chicken and rice
you got chicken that that's what you ditch for chicken and
rice that's like the most plain as shit ever you ditched a
very important tournament by the way this has more money
than pro league and you ditch that for chicken and rice wait
what is our drop spot launch site okay technically you're
not wrong it have more money than yeah yeah let me raise
your volume up a little bit so like what's this track here
um i don't know i mean i'm just gonna play how we like how a
normal game does i don't think it's gonna be any different
it's not gonna be any different i have a team i have a team
that wants we're getting conned maybe yeah we're just gonna
land here okay
Lance here, try and like push out here and kill them.
Alright, okay, no problem.
I don't know if anybody landed near us.
I don't see anyone.
I think we're good.
Are we good?
Nice.
Nothing ever goes wrong for us.
It's off to a good start.
There's a hemlock there next to that if you need.
Yeah, I dropped a havoc.
I heard havoc.
I heard havoc's good this season.
Wait, zipping up towards South... What the fuck?
leave so there is a team all right okay it might start
peeking out of the glass all right i'm gonna go right yeah
move right and steal all this loot all right these guys are
gonna have like literally nothing if you see a shotgun let
me know like a mastiff would be huge all right all right all
right oh and we got an evo harvester here we're gonna have
blues we can literally roll these guys uh i have an alt
excel i can use that right now Do I want the throw?
Oh, here's a PK.
Nice, yeah.
Do I want the throw range or the residual toxins?
The vision.
The vision?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a massive.
Nice.
I'm going to drop PK.
Oh, and that?
I'm juiced.
There's a...
You need bats?
I have four...
Three bats.
I got two.
Whoa!
Oh, no, I didn't see him.
They're pushing.
I cracked him.
I cracked Nibi.
No, I dropped behind you.
No!
I didn't see him.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Dang, that sucks.
So was it worth it for chicken and rice?
Was it...
Was the chicken and rice worth it?
What is it?
No, no.
Oh, man.
I can't believe it.
My first game where I died, not top 10.
I'm lucky.
GG's, though.
That was a...
I don't think that was like even...
That was a quick one.
Yeah, that wasn't even one minute.
I don't think so.
Hey, at least that's $100, you know?
that's that's one way to look at it yeah yeah it basically
paid off your chicken and rice uh-huh a lot of chicken and
yeah a lot of yeah yeah at least here
it's all right we look at the positives here
it's okay as long as it's more than pro league that's all
that matters you got the we got the All right, I'm gonna eat
my food.
GG's, though.
GG's.
Good luck in your next game, too.
Good luck.
Guys, I don't think it's worth the chicken and rice.
I don't think it was worth this chicken and rice, guys.
I don't think the chicken and rice was worth it.
I didn't see them, too.
I died so fast.
But hey, the food.
The food's though.
Thanks, Medi.
Drop's audio volume was pretty.
Thanks, guys.
Guys, I gotta play one minute with Drop, guys.
Guys, I gotta play...
That's all that matters.
That's all...
Holy shit Oh my god That actually was the fastest game ever
The worst part is that it's duos So I have to wait even
longer Because there's more people That's I think that's the
worst part There's more people So I have to wait longer
Oh my god it's okay it's okay now we're gonna we're gonna be
nice wake we're gonna commentate we're gonna commentate i'll
never forgive chicken and rice i'll never forget this oh yes
this is a perfect time to share by the way guys by the way
guys i got sponsored by gamer subs i'm an me like turn down
the volume let me it okay yes i am an official gamer subs
partner now chat okay maybe not all the way down like i need
some ambience here um but not only okay wait i shouldn't
okay please officially a gamer subs partner use dokey bird
for 10 off all purchase This is a great time.
I died early so I can I can chill
Okay guys, so what that means is that I not only have a code
but also so like if you use the code Obviously like
obviously because I'm sponsored I get Using the code really
helps a lot for me and also I will have an official gamer
subs cup It's called a waifu cup.
That would be the only...
It's called a waifu cup, but it's basically a...
You know, like, the cup to use to put your gamer subs in.
Or, you know, hold water or anything.
It's like a Stanley cup, but better.
But cheaper, you know?
But not...
It's like a Stanley cup, but, like, not over...
What was it called?
Not over...
What's the word called when it's, like, over height?
What's that word called?
There's a specific word for it.
Uh, so better, yes, of course it's better.
It's gonna have my face on it.
Uh, no, no, no,
but for gamers.
Oh yeah, not overrated, exactly.
Goodbye Stanley Cup sponsors.
But if Stanley Cup wants to sponsor me as well, if Stanley
Cup wants to sponsor me as well, they're not overrated, but
they are currently because I'm sponsored by Gaming
Yourself's.
Anyway, anyway, uh, uh, uh, what was I saying?
Oh yeah, uh, there's gonna be There's going to be an art
contest that's going to start next week.
And basically, whoever wins the art contest will have their
art on my waifu cup and also win some prize money.
It was originally, Gamer Stubs originally sponsored 5K for
the art contest.
Rules will be given on April 5th on how to submit.
But Gamer Stubs originally, this is all paid by Gamer Stubs
by the way, they put out 5K for the art contest.
But I wanted to choose more people.
So I added like 2K out of my own pocket.
Because I want to be able to pay for more art.
Like because you know guys are...
I feel like you guys are going to submit so many beautiful
art.
I want to be able to compensate as many artists as I can.
So I decided to pay 2K out of my own pocket to add to the
prize pool.
So it went from 5K to 7K.
Just so I could be able to pick more artists.
But only one artist will be on the cup.
Only one artist will be on the cup.
And yes.
So, yes, using my code helps out a lot.
It really does.
And it's on every purchase, all purchase and everything.
So, like, anything you want to buy, just use my code.
I get 10% off.
And Gamerselfs actually sent me, like, a package of their
stuff.
Like, a bunch of...
Like, they sent me, like, $300 worth of Gamerself products
for free to try them out and everything.
And, like, as you guys know, I love free stuff, so...
Also my referral link!
Oh my god, my mod My mod is a better streamer than I am Let
me, I didn't even remember I had a referral link I'm sorry,
gamer subs I actually did not remember
Give me a sec I also have a referral link By the way, guys
Let me grab the referral link Real quick, chat Guys, you
guys know so much more thank you thank you all right let's
see okay here you go and then i'm gonna i'm gonna repin this
i'm gonna repin this real quick uh here you go guys use my
referral link too thank you much thank you i really
appreciate it but anyway as i was saying uh uh
Um, I didn't get to try all of them yet, but like, I think
they're all, I think that I really like so far is the melon
one.
The melon one's really nice.
I really like the melon flavor.
And there was like one more that I also like, but I don't
remember what it was called.
It was, uh, I think it was the peach one.
The melon and the peach one were, were really good.
I haven't tried everyone.
Look, guys, I was in $300 worth of products.
I was not, I, I did not have a lot of time.
try out the rest there were a lot i didn't have time to try
out all of them but peach and melon were currently my
favorites so far out of all the ones i was able to try of
all of them i was able to try peach and the melon the peach
and melon one was pretty good um other than that let's see
i'm trying to think what else i need to show uh but yes look
forward to the art contest look forward to the art contest
and i'm really really there's also a lot of really good
back-to-back news later on so there might be more stuff
being announced later on so um i'm trying to make sure to
like not overwhelm you guys too much with everything because
there is a lot of news so i'm trying my best to like not
overwhelm you guys yes my scars cup i got invited to my
first JP tournament.
That's Doki.
That's really um, I don't know if I can tell you who my
teammates are.
I already know who my teammates are.
Uh, but like they can speak English.
So, um, so like that's all I can say.
But I don't know if I can I mean that sort of like tells you
who my teammates are because like there's not like because
like um, it like limits, I guess it like narrows down the
participants.
of who they are so yeah that that narrows a lot of people
it narrows down a lot of people in general so like teammates
can speak you can communicate in english with me so i won't
be you know so i won't be like a hazard
um but yes i will be participating in my first uh japanese
tournament um it has a lot of like insane gamers out there.
Like, you know, like there's like this tournament, there's a
lot of like professional players here.
Um, it's like one professional player and two content
creators, basically, per team.
And, and, uh, and I'm gonna, uh, and like, I think it is on.
Tapie's in it.
Tapie's in there.
Our, our Apex Oshi.
He'll forever be my Apex Oshi because of the smile
Apex Oshi One Tappy I sorry That emotes like honestly my
Favorite
Someone Post a smile so we can copy And paste it Tappy our
Apex Oshi But yes, I think that is all the news I can I have
announced karaoke has been rescheduled to you know I can
even tell you guys my schedule right now.
I finalized my schedule next week I'll be taking three rest
days technically is three rest days due to everything that's
going on so I have shadow Colossus shadow Colossus on Monday
Snuffy collab on Wednesday and Snuffy is gonna tour...
She's gonna tour...
Fucking...
Snuffy is gonna give me a tour on Roblox.
She was very excited about that.
She was...
She was like...
Oh my god.
What have you...
Can I tour...
Give you like... Show you all my favorite Roblox servers?
And I was like...
You know what?
I'm down.
Okay, to be fair.
First we were like, oh my god, we should do Warrior Cats.
Because in the past, we actually really wanted collab in the
past and do a Warrior Cats RP server on Roblox.
Because Warrior Cats official server, Warrior Cats has an
official Roblox server.
And we've always wanted to do that.
But we never got the perms to do it.
So then we were like, oh my god, is it time?
gonna do our warrior cats rp roblox collab and then stuffy
was like oh my god can i give you a tour on roblox but i
can't show you like all my favorite roblox server and i was
like you know what let's give me the tour give me the tour
so we're gonna have a we're gonna have a roblox collab
together um on wednesday and then i think after that um it's
karaoke on Friday and then Scars Cup.
I think okay, no, Scars Cup!
Sorry, Scars Cup first and then karaoke later on.
I think like Scars Cup is like at 2 in the morning and then
oh, okay, dude.
Wait, the team I spectate died.
When did they die?
I don't even remember they died.
Okay, anyway, anyway, after that is Scars Cup at 2 in the
morning, karaoke at 5 and then the day after that is
challenger circuit with wig and tempo and i hope to fucking
i hope to fucking god that uh
i i hope it's not seven hours i really hope it's not seven
hours
i'm just you know when tempo told me it's a seven hour long
day i thought he meant like overall He was like no, it's
just for one day.
I was like What?
And then Whig was like, okay, but theoretically only if we
make it to the next day.
So like it's all It's all about like, you know, making it to
the next day And stuff.
It's like theoretically There's a chance that we get
eliminated early So like let's hope to No, we're going to do
our best We're going to do our best chat We're going to try
our best Here.
We're not going to fuck around oh yeah i'll also be playing
off stream with tempo and wake they might be streaming it i
might i'm not i i i already have two apex streams next to me
so i was just like i'm just gonna play off stream with them
yeah so we're gonna try our best here okay chat i think
that's everything is that everything i think so i think that
is everything i've denounced mod has i have i missed Did I
miss anything?
See you, Rick.
Yeah, we're gonna, we're gonna, I'm gonna be playing Rink
on, uh, on Wig's stream.
I'm pretty sure he's gonna be streaming.
He streams every fucking day, almost.
Anything else?
Is everything good to go?
Wait, maybe, I'm gonna check if they announced games four
yet.
What is game four?
We had three more games.
Oh, 30 versus 30!
There's no way I can drag down my team.
down 29 other people.
There's 30 versus 30 people.
There's Shirley.
Shirley.
I can uh oh!
Last week to pre-order the Lunar New Year merch!
By the way!
This is the last week to pre-order the Lunar New Year merch
chat.
um we have one more week left we have one more week for
lunar new year merch um people who ordered the buttons and
stickers might only the buttons and stickers might receive
them earlier because i actually received the stickers before
anything else so so you might receive your stickers um only
for people who order stickers only the only the people who
only order the stickers and buttons because um they
separated the delivery and i received the stickers first so
so the other stuff will take a while to arrive the other
stuff will still take quite a bit to arrive to us what does
everything else ship out uh most likely uh may may or june
most likely it's around may or june um the reason being is
that the products are shipped via A fucking giant boat.
Like, I used the ocean to ship my products because there's a
lot of them.
And, like, by air was really fucking expensive.
Like, yeah, I may receive them in, like, two to three weeks.
But there were a lot of them.
By air, it was a lot of them.
So, like, it was easier to just do it by cargo and by ship.
Wait, who won?
Yeah, it's gonna go, it's gonna deliver by a boat.
So that's why it's gonna take a bit to get here.
Like, it was literally, like, if I chose plain option, it
would have been like, if I chose the plain option, it would
have been, it would have been so fucking expensive.
Like, it would have been, like, half the, it would have
been, like, half the price of the merch.
And I was like, I was just like, what the fuck?
So I was like, nah, fuck that.
Fuck that.
Holy shit.
I do not need that.
Alright, let's see.
Where are we?
Where's Joki?
Where's the...
Are we in red or blue?
I'm blue.
I'm with Nadi and...
Dahl.
Nadi.
Nadi's a roller player, right?
I need to brush up on my...
my apex pro player um apex pro nani uh wait right or is he
yes battle beaver i knew it i knew it my my first wait no
wasn't dropped is drop roller i don't remember i actually
don't i don't remember my apex pro player lore it's been way
too long way too long I don't remember my oh yeah Jen Jen
was roller yeah but we were fucking punching people that
doesn't count it doesn't count because we were punching
people okay you can just maybe want but you have to stick
with your team has the drops for both sides for a man as you
spend and figure out which team gets which class the winning
team whatever whatever how I leaked the code.
Okay, guys, we're gonna get random people joining in because
Hal accidentally leaked the code.
Yeah, we're...
Literally, I leaked the code.
Alright, I hope he did it, Ashley.
You said he was gonna do that.
Wait, what?
What the hell?
Sorry.
all right it's okay you guys got to rewind to find it did he
actually i can't tell if he was around just if we did if he
did people would fucking join in right now all right i'm
trying to see what's the next option all right let's see uh
we are in does this game for a drop what the fuck is this
are we c or a my my brain okay i think it didn't help that i
woke up 30 minutes before the stream i took a nap i took i
took a nap before okay we are assault then which one's
controller wait this map is so confusing we're salt okay we
got what the fuck is that yellow is no man's land you cannot
go in there until you see an admin type this is actually i
thought we're gonna be like playing control or something i
thought okay so we're playing storm point and we're going on
the side on the right what is my team number we got a new
code guys he actually did leaked it
i thought it was a joke but he did it that madman he
actually did it
i thought he was just fucking around our ceo guys all right
let's see format what's the next other games 5 and 6 5 and 6
is no 3 strikes again and then punching again so this is a
lot okay so team 5 is also 3 strikes okay uh we are uh with
team 16.
all right team 16.
let's see that's our CEO the thing out does for content
let's see 16.
hello hello hi hello let's go all right what are we playing
playing we have like 30 yeah yeah yeah but like what what
what legends are we doing oh assault so anyone from the
assault oh shit I that's what it meant oh I was so confused
I was like what does that even mean I was like hey guys I'm
the content creator here on this team as you can tell as you
kids can tell the only times I play apex is when I get
invited all right so what we're all supposed to be in like
separate discords or all together in one well we can do we
can do all together sorry it's like a choice you can either
be in one voice chat which I think you know 30 people in the
voice chat is a little bit fucked up or you can like join
together in like your own team voice oh my god is the team 6
what is going on there six is the controller team okay yeah
who's who though like if that's the other team or if that's
us no that's the other team because like uh how's in there
so how's on the controller side so like you can tell that
our team is very corny no one's taking control over here I
can tell that start telling everyone to move to 13 yeah I
think it's 13.
Go 13.
Oh, 13?
Okay.
Oh, no.
I don't want all of us in the same voice.
No.
I'm muted myself, guys.
Y'all, if you're being a salt character, don't kill me.
don't shoot each other please what if we just no no hear me
i hear me out what if we just 30 man rat in one building
we're going against controllers but okay one of us out of
the 30 of us should know where zone is right yeah yeah
that's the whole point if we get to the building first we
win yep i think timmy's on to something okay low key that
might work yo that's what i'm imagine like we all got a
maggie and we all drilling them too
i'm just nervous i'm just nervous for all the rollers like
don't don't shoot all i saw characters oh my amos this is
about to go crazy i think amos this is about to pull us bro
hey mk up right now i forgot mk is up yo mk it's like Samma
down, Simma down.
I'm about to see.
Just make sure we calm, like, really, really hard this game.
Should we at least have one Maggie on every team, by the
way?
I feel like prize and aim assist.
Like, imagine...
Maggie fuse.
Oh, my God.
I mean, I mean, if we all have...
If we all have Bangalore and then we have Zone, we just
Bangalore them and they can't cross.
And then they put Watson on the team so we can all use the
one-tone.
Nah, it would be fine.
We didn't need to pick the next time.
I don't need ballistics, so we just all insta-reload.
Does it work for everybody?
Bro, Noddy literally left our...
Noddy's like...
Noddy's like crashing somebody else's VC.
He's not even in this one.
Bro, what the fuck?
I got peer pressure doing this.
Noddy literally fucking joined some other VC.
He's not even with us.
What the fuck is this bullshit?
I sucked it up.
We have one single ass.
So we're drilling people now.
What if we have three teams?
Three teams are ash and then they just fucking they're like
the secret agents and shit.
Yeah, they're like the power rangers.
Who's the best rat out of all of us?
Me.
Is that...
I'm so sorry about it.
this is so fucking awkward man this is so oh yeah oh and
we're missing half like too many cooks we go mills and down
beasts king paul is gonna go i think we're on the east side
no we have to yeah we want to we want to make sure to split
it bro all the controller pros all the controller pros like
fucking left us they're in their own voice chat this is so
fucked up not even joined the controller pros voice chat bro
what the fuck
there's like naughty psych zy new and fun and like they're
all in their own fucking voice chat Let's do two lightning
rods, two Zeus, one command, probably one storm.
I think one, we should go cascade balls, and then they can
go towards Jurassic.
We should have one, maybe one team launch pad, one team loot
the bridge up high, and then they can go pylon, and then one
devastate and one echo.
All right, good.
Now who's going to do any of that?
Wait, wait, wait, how much are we assigning this to
everybody?
I'm just going to say team 14 will take storm catcher
because that's our team.
to do minus just said team 11 to 20 left side of map oh what
left side of map see our plan i think for voice call as well
though should we have like two teams per voice call so we
don't clutter everyone no uh like or you want to just like
like all do our comms in here it's just we don't have to
like just ping in game don't yeah i mean like i don't know i
wouldn't want to come in here Oh, light mag, like 50 of us
saying it.
Yeah, I know.
It's pretty much the same resume or push this guy at the
building.
That is lean.
Like, initially, just point at your monitor.
Point at your monitor.
Just point them out.
Don't cross.
I think I didn't initially call it.
I didn't left side or right side.
Because then you will finish them, please.
Holy crap.
We're right side.
Can this work?
I'm writing something for you guys.
what if i just join the other voice chat nice oh bet so i'll
go on launchpad perfect all i need to know yeah that's fine
perfect not delete it so they don't find they don't get the
strategy there's no uh there's no command on that list so
could have team 11 that's so helpful sure and then pylons 11
command yeah
Let's see how many cars are there.
Bang Fuse and Maggie, right?
Where do we all want to meet up?
Big Fuse, Maggie, okay.
Oh, this is no name.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is so chaotic.
We should most likely group up at...
Drop, can you start doing some IGL calls?
Bro, you want me to fucking pipe up?
A pipe up.
Big, mad Maggie, Fuse.
We need to divvy up where people are going.
We have it.
That's already in there.
IGL isn't even with us!
paying attention we need a new commander i think our
commander is lost already our pro player actually isn't even
i'm down for 10 years he left us with the other controller
pros i changed 11 to 12 for command because pylon's not in
that's no man's land joined the controller pro side so one
one time where are we all landing look at turn in the chat
make sure you pick your characters.
What's not okay?
I guess I'll do manbaggy.
I'm literally in the lobby.
I'm looking at the lobby.
I did it.
Oh, that's someone already DC'd.
I might have to restart.
Yeah, tell them.
Wait, who's too loud?
I don't even know who's too loud.
There's 30 people.
They're going to restart.
They're probably restart.
Okay, I turned it down.
Guys, the thing is, I don't even know who's too loud.
There's 30 people in here.
I can't even town they're not restarting not restarting oh
yeah guys you know this this server definitely does not have
any boost right now that's not having a pylon right like
once he's put start oh yeah we all need that pylon yeah once
he typed start no i don't think everyone but i feel like the
bottom side of the map teams should all move there and then
group up and then we need to like group up i mean we're we
don't know where the zone's going to be right because
there's going to be zones like you can tell the server is
boostless i say we wait it's so crunchy yeah i mean i think
in general we should probably just group up or like half
those cascades half those pylon and then we can just kind of
meet we also we're all going zeus by the way we also have
dogs on that north side that is available so one of you guys
should do that too oh yeah that's all available to us yeah
yeah you think i'm breaking the rules from standing outside
the line to command i hit that spider in the line
yeah make the spiders come to you i feel like we need a hard
real height like on everything i do want to also point out
we probably should have roughly peter 30 30 snipers they
have ramp walls so we do need to break those they're gonna
have rampart walls okay what the fuck why did they get the
good side spamming not the closest at the rampart walls i'm
saying because if smokes why did people just shoot the wall
as they're replacing it it's not fair once you die oh no
people dc'd what do you yeah people dc'd again oh wait
there's like 10 dc they're gonna restart the lobby again oh
my god Get the 30-30 game out of my life faster.
Or so is the voice better?
I lowered the volume.
Is it better now?
No, I'll play now.
Just 30 people come out of a portal.
Oh my God.
If somebody wants to be quirky and play Ash, is the volume
better now?
There you go.
Okay, I'll be a little lower.
you code right it has to be please why is this game the one
that is the hardest to start this is the game that i'm most
uncomfortable with because there's too many people
my introvert ass can handle this i'm gonna repost our thing
i was gonna post it to you thank you
this is too many cucks
and suffering please my social battery is getting ready
too many cooks oh i lost too many cooks no i'm just loading
back in because too many cooks uh okay they didn't give me
the second time but i'm gonna go relay the information to
our other people's okay i'm picking a bright orange ash skin
so everyone knows okay wait no one is no one oh my god we're
coordinating our skins to a color how cute would that be
that would be that would be we need people going bean by the
way or Is it Is it Is it Cascade Balls?
Balls, yeah Yeah I'm so confused That whole like Those
buildings On the south North of Pylon We gotta We gotta We
gotta have Another team From Command Center Go down there
You know what's funny chat The other side The other chat
Take the grab Down All of them are like United and together
And then there's our team Or the controller players Really
left into Their own voice chat Like yeah i mean you are oh
yeah the the thing you listed by the way of two-team deuce i
feel like one of those teams needs to be digging towards
lighting up our team the controller players don't even want
to be together with us like that's our team
the other team the mouse and keyboard players and the roller
players are united together or like one one from command
yeah probably yeah probably one of the command teams of team
12 cascade balls.
You mean team 11?
I just thought it was so funny.
I never knew it was called that.
It's literally all the roller players, too.
They're balls.
They're just like, we're out of here.
And someone from Zeus needs to do that.
Wait, we don't know, never mind.
Are these guys?
Are they stealing our shot right now?
No, we gave them time i think we're just waiting on uh red
to connect wait did like drop leave to the to see the
controller gang it's not even controller what are you doing
here get out
drop leave their voice chat you're not even part of that
group think they will job left to check on the controller
game controller players go to one side and then the mk
players go the other side oh they came back john came back
we divvy it divvy it the uh the controller players put one
in like like their centrists what if we divide the role
players go stand in the corner i mean they're already doing
that i'm plugging in the keys right now they're already
doing that why he got a turret stop becoming one of you man
maggie time welcome to the dark side i don't know what the
strat is so who's using a charge rifle i don't know who what
the strat is i'm just gonna play the game i'm just gonna
play i don't even know what this i tuned out the strat which
is pretty bad i should not have tuned out everybody starts
screaming i have no idea where we're going and drop ship and
drop let's go because we got house so let's go we're going
launch pad will it take us a command center guys no i can't
be the first one in this team to die there's 30 of us uh i
can't loot backside i'm gonna start from the front i'm gonna
loot front of storm point our storm catcher wait what are
the other assault camp i need the it up i'm really confused
okay ash fuse mad maggie bangalore rev okay okay if i up
it's not my fault we're not sharing storm catcher if i up
it's not my fault i got overwhelmed i'm gonna follow naughty
my feelings well just trying to figure out well run figure
out what's open so you can run to wherever yeah beans beans
open Bean is open.
All right.
Our pro player's not even with us.
Is our team out here?
I'm here.
Who am I looking at with their nice little sword here?
Our pro player's not even in our foot chat.
Bro.
He loves us.
Oh my god.
Almost killed.
You look great.
Okay.
They got zone.
Nobody can.
Wait.
They got zone.
What the fuck?
It's because somebody code net.
Somebody code net.
Nope.
Bro.
That's fucked up.
insane that's really bad that's really bad because they're
defenders or what they they have the whole time bro you see
the rocks and shit over there they're just they literally
have red pipes we're just gonna yeah we're just gonna flank
them like fucking normandy bro go all the way this side the
side gonna hit a hot flank uh i need a backpack bro we might
as well cross the nomads man at this point they got full on
if you guys if you guys need like specific loot with your
team you should probably just type in game if it's possible
that's probably the best way yeah or voice chat yeah oh my
god i got so scared i want to do that too wait did i stole
somebody's loot i might have wait no we got this is my loot
now oh my god we're so fucking starting already you're
starting okay oh shit what the fuck we just show, I think.
Honestly, I think we just...
We have to go.
probably just in the onsad right now.
I'll jive, I'll jive.
I'm about to go all the way up toward the wall.
IGL's, where do you want us to go?
IGL's.
Yeah, where should we meet?
I mean, we can think about where we should meet.
We should meet Cascades.
Cascades.
Yeah, I'm down.
Yeah, we need to get our harvesters, but fuck.
Yeah, we need to all get our armors up.
I'm gonna do those command sweaters.
You guys have to like split up, split up and like send each
guy like different harvesters.
Yeah.
Where's Naughty going?
It's a unit, the ITL unit.
They're gonna be sitting behind walls for sure.
Hmm.
I don't want to get triple shot on.
Do we think banks should take ultimate cooldown or tap
cooldown?
I think ult would go crazy right now.
Alt cooldown, yeah.
That's our teammate, right?
Yeah, they're on our side.
But if you die, you back from up here.
Probably mute so the people alive won't get confused.
Oh, it's ain't good.
Makes sense.
You should just stop calling out while you're down.
Just rage really hard.
Screaming you're holding knockdown.
Guys, I could have put the descript list of all the people
that's in our voice.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, what the?
Why is this guy shooting at us?
bro is it we can there's a stupid bang right there we can
farm armors off them can we how does this round work we have
to cross to the other side we have to cross here we should
shoot each other we should shoot each other for evo
but then we're just we're gonna lose our shields It's bro.
Yeah, oh wait, wait, wait.
Wait, that's actually smart as fuck.
Wait, they're Watson too so they get to re they can just
spam it.
They're completely just dumb.
That would think about it.
What do we want?
Wrecking ball catches fire.
Okay, Wrecking ball.
And to one of the cars.
Who's cars here?
That's us.
Okay.
Oh, you're back.
So let me go.
I'm with you.
I'm with you on your left rim.
I need you.
I'm looking for looking for juice for us.
Yo, pylon is still on Luda, guys, by the way.
Yeah, I'm going to pylon right now.
You can loot up.
we can do like the um the animal plis real quick too or
whatever the oh yeah yeah it's probably important we get
those for attachments i'm literally like tuning out what
they're saying and just following naughty right now i that's
my strat i'm gonna believe in the controller i think they're
all group in the controller squad i'm gonna shoot in pylon
right now just make sure yeah you're good bro we're in pylon
or the council of idea There's too many people too many
cooks too many cooks Anyone Jurassic do we know?
No, we're in Jurassic.
I'm in Jurassic right now.
We're in Jurassic.
Okay, we're at barometer
Well, I like nothing.
I feel so poor Advantage is gonna go crazy.
I have like nothing on my nemesis Yeah, we should have
better on them Too many cooks.
They have their entire side selling, so...
That's not big.
I think they would have gone to like hide in the corner like
really quick.
We should have had the one, the map would have no zones.
In my opinion, we should honestly start grouping now and go
kill them because they are 100% running around the map
trying to get their evas up.
Like we should like try to pick them because I...
We're trying to regroup.
What spot are we regrouping at?
Barrow, you think?
I mean, I just saw two of them just waste evac.
So they're coming.
We should go to mill right now.
We should all go towards mill and try to kill people.
mill okay okay for the mill so far give us time though
because is that one of us that hit kenneth yeah yeah damn
that's us look at us go
where's the cascades the ideal council has arrived everyone
in cascades oh my god the mad maggie we should have flanked
it we probably take like godrock island or something all
right bullets the ash yeah you're talking about like which
side of the map come from north side like milk side if we go
mid side yeah i i go and then we go like we go godrock and
then we can scout her yeah yeah okay they're gonna go
godrock that's everything i registered we were we're in um
cita okay i'm gonna see it works here as well that's
everything i could register from this 30 man chat oh my god
what the fuck is his own what the fuck is his own oh my god
what the fuck why did he get everything have a balloon we
can already have a balloon just let me know when oh oh those
can fucking take the balloon Keep going towards
One at a time, everybody There's gunshots and checkpoints
who's in checkpoints Where's Naughty?
That's us.
We're shooting spiders.
Where's Naughty?
Do spiders here.
Where's my, I see that.
I see that.
I see him on that Godwaker now.
Where's my, oh Naughty's behind us.
They're over there.
This is a bad zone.
We can't use any Bengals.
Wait a minute.
They're there.
We go Seenote then, right?
No one's guarding the left side of Seenote right here.
Like the far left side entrance of Seenote.
All right.
We're going to go.
Yeah, we're going to go.
We should probably group up now.
Yeah.
Towards Barrow.
Okay.
Go Bean.
Yeah.
I have a two by four.
Yeah, let's do it.
Where are you going, Nuddy?
We probably need to wait for a bunch of people too.
Right here.
There's only no one here.
There's no one holding the side.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Which side are you talking about?
Oh, he's getting the armor.
He's getting the armor.
Left side of Sino.
I don't want to be like...
Get in, get in, get in, get in, get in, get in.
Get in the hill.
Oh, they might be there.
Is that them?
Yeah, yeah, that's him.
I'm in Sanote now.
I'm in Sanote.
Yeah, we're moving up.
There's nobody close buildings.
Nobody close to Sanote buildings.
Nice, nice.
So you guys are at Mills?
You're good at Mills?
We're good at Mills.
We're going Bean right now.
Okay, we're following.
Yep.
And we're moving.
We're moving into Sino.
I'm waiting for you guys.
We should probably just group up here and wait for everyone
before .
On the main hill.
Yeah.
Will you allow them to take care packs then?
Yeah, I'll stay.
I'm so scared.
I don't see anybody.
Oh, I see them!
Look at their fucking shims!
Going for care pack.
Go for the care pack.
Oh my god, do you see that?
Oh my god.
What the?
This is not fair.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
What the fuck am I looking at?
You should stick with your teammates, by the way.
Holy shit.
Dude, they're literally just sitting on top of those rocks.
I'm sad.
Bro, I would be on THAT team!
They're gonna have console.
They're gonna have console, bro.
Bro!
They have a console in there, too.
I would be on that team!
Yeah, I believe in this zone.
Yeah, we need to talk...
They made it new POI.
They're gonna be careful.
They're gonna have Watsongens and stuff.
Yeah, that actually is very true.
Oh my god.
You said backside, south side of Cino.
Yeah, it just ends on them, bro.
All Cino's open.
Okay, it might be the one in the far back by the way.
It's like car losses here.
Yeah Yeah
Yeah, can we can we fight left building the far left
building break all this up.
Yeah, we're here like we're here with the Yeah, I'm so I'm
so in them I'm so in them I can get the ash under the
building.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you should do that.
You should do that.
Give me a smug to run into.
Yeah, yeah.
That's actually crazy.
You're ready to take the ash, you boys.
They have the hole.
Yep.
Oh, I'm lagging in the server.
Yeah.
Wait, I got knocked.
Tifa.
Yeah.
I got full knocked.
Wait, careful guys.
You might be shooting.
What's in one HP inside?
The rev is one shot.
Oh, no.
120.
I'm breaking the down.
Breaking the jam.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm following the crowd.
I knocked one.
Can't one not to kill each other.
I can't tell.
I can't.
There's so many.
Don't bang all.
Do not bang all.
We're going to kill each other.
I'm on roof.
I'm just...
Oh my god!
We're going in!
I can't...
We need to get inside the building if you can.
Okay, take in the building.
Oh, my, my, my, my, my.
I got to the desk.
Okay, I'm inside, I'm safe.
I'll bring an ulti out of this bag all.
What is this?
What is going on?
A storm?
I think I'm dead, I'm dead.
Deeds, you can rest, Deeds.
I'm coming.
I'm knocked, I'm knocked.
Fuck, I'm dead.
I might try to rest you, Mario.
I try to take the zip behind you guys and they just try to
look at me right here.
They're all trying to fucking push up.
Oh my God.
Are we in the building or?
I can't see.
I don't know who's my teammate.
I literally can't see.
Oh wait, it's almost finishing.
I have a respawn beacon.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Bring around your teammates.
Is that the enemy?
I can't tell.
I actually can't tell.
Oh, fuck, okay.
There's too many people.
Let me know.
I need a run.
Oh, shit.
I stormed the beam.
I can grab you.
Like water.
It's okay, good try, good try.
We're still in, we're still inside the building.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh my god, this is water.
Are you good?
I'm good.
Yes, yes, the building is still in.
I'm going.
We need to get inside.
I think we need to get inside.
Can we try to- Yeah, we do.
We need to get inside.
Some of them have blue armors in the building on the left.
in which building are we drilling they're all they're
playing the opposite side from us no one's inside middle
right now as far as i can tell see if you can show up the
building i'm gonna respawn you ghost empire close so here i
was gonna destroy this one give me my baby oh my god
This is war!
I just spawned in.
I don't know, I don't know.
You guys need to smoke the zip.
You guys need to smoke the zip if you can.
Someone smoked the cross so I can mess with your teammate.
There's so many things going on!
You guys, if you're gonna do it, you have to try right now.
With the Maggie ball.
No!
The fucking gas!
I couldn't tell which one.
I already used it.
Guys, naughty, naughty, naughty, you're so fucked.
Nadi, you're so fucked, Nadi.
Use my, you got this.
There's so many armor swaps, there's no way.
I have no more shoes.
Yeah,
anyone here on this side of- I don't know, man.
Nadi, come on, Nadi.
Nadi, I'm literally, I know you're confused, but I'm
literally your teammate, Nadi.
Nadi, I'm literally your teammate.
Nadi, Riz!
Nadi, I'm literally your teammate, Nadi!
I know you're confused because there's so many people, but
I'm literally your teammate!
I'm sorry, Nadi.
I'm back here inside of Sino with you guys.
You guys got any meds?
I'm pretty low.
Of course the moment he Riz is...
Bro, bro, bro, this is like the most unfair game
Oh my god This is actually the most unfair game ever To me
Oh my god He hesitated I was so free to rest for the longest
time.
This is actually Oh, I can't believe we actually had to run
the beach.
I can't believe we actually had to do that.
We had to storm the beach.
That's actually crazy that that happened.
That was actually fucking crazy.
Like, but like it was the most unfair to us because we had
to run to the beach we were with a team that had to run
across the beach against defense like what the fuck there
really is a war war never changes bro there's no way that
we're our team's still alive there's no fucking I don't
think I don't think I There's no way the assault characters
are alive.
There's no fucking way.
I think we're all dead I legitimately think we're all dead
War it never changes it really does War is not fair toky bro
look at how many of the defenders they're still alive like
they all Only lost five people!
Oh my god!
That's only five people died.
That's actually crazy!
This is 100% defense-sided.
I lost the 50-50 chat.
I lost the lottery to be on team defense.
I...
This is what Normandy feels like.
Oh my god.
They got the fucking...
They got the map.
They got the zone.
And they also got like...
They got the zone as defenders.
I think that's the worst part.
If they were playing the same...
I think if they were playing the same...
If they were on assault characters, I think it would be more
fair.
fact that like they got the controller class and zone that
was that was fucked up man that was so fucked up they
actually won the gotcha yeah they got the best possible zone
for this fight
holy shit that's so funny that's actually so funny i can't
believe we have to run at the beach.
I can't believe that.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we had to run at the beach.
It's so poetic.
It actually is.
The thing is, I was so confused because I was worried I was
going to shoot my old teammates.
That was the worst part.
I was just like, who's my teammate it doesn't matter when
you're in a fight there's so many people around me I
couldn't tell and then we couldn't use Bangalore alt because
we can alt ourselves so it was like we couldn't use
Bangalore alt because we didn't want to kill ourselves with
Bangalore alt it's actually crazy
Oh my god, they're fighting each other.
We're fisting again.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's back to fisting.
Oh my god.
I like how we had, like, no man's land.
We established no man's land.
We're like, oh, you can't cross no man's land.
But it didn't matter because the zone was, like, their zone.
So we had to cross.
We had...
Oh my god, we were all here.
here for this the apex civil war we were all here for the
apex civil war chat okay oh my god
oh true they're gens you're right because they established
the gens war war never changes we didn't get the zone or the
class we wanted
yeah we had the middle zone it would have been more balanced
that was crazy though the fucking wall that they made that
was insane like looking at that wall live was actually
insane i can't believe that that was real i i can't believe
that was that i saw that and then the and and then the final
zone was at the beach that was actually the craziest part
that the final zone was at the fucking beach like yeah take
notes guys take notes all right how much was that That was
My gosh Oh my god They get double the fucking price for that
Okay let me I need to know how much I got for that I must
like get like a hundred or some shit Alright 4,500 Divide by
30 150 I got 150 for that Nice That's fine 150 is nice Yeah
we got like major fucked up We actually got major fucked up
there there's me i'm with dwells and sweet x sage dwells
who's dwells
oh he's the console preyed he's console preyed that's even
better
all right let's see um and then i don't know who the other
are my other one is this is like let me check up x sweet
sage this is the right one no I typed it wrong I was like
that's not the right one
okay our pro player is a console spread it's three strikes
okay but does he does he have like the the wanes okay Okay,
code is up.
All right.
Code.
We got the code.
All right.
We are team.
What team are we?
I already forgot our team.
We are team.
15.
We're 15.
Oh yeah, Shraco.
Make sure you drink lots of water.
make sure don't don't be don't drink balance it out with
water and stay safe man stay safe kill me my team 15 again
all right team 15 all right holy that was like bro what the
fuck was that game
I'm still trying to I'm still fucking processing what we
just played like it was actually saving Private Ryan right
there but what if we failed like
oh my god it's actually insane alright uh i went through
some ptsd shit right there all right we're joining we're
supposed to join team 15 team 15.
hello hello hello my yo evan bro hit him for like 20 damage
what is unfortunate okay which were you guys on the control
or were you guys on the winning team or the losing team
because i felt like losing team okay were we all were we all
losing okay what the fuck was that what they got the beach
we recreated we recreated world war two but like my history
of playing apex legends the last four years have i ever seen
that zone we we literally had to storm the beach but like we
lost like that's not what history taught me what the
happened history didn't teach me this like over my frames
were dying i was on like 90 frames you were on 90 frames
aren't you on roller you don't need the frames yes i do
you're on roller i can't even shoot my gun it was terrible
that's terrible of course they get the zone and they were on
control they were on the controller characters like what the
fuck yeah no that zone is crazy i've never seen end on that
little rock like that it was actually fucking insane
apparently only five people died on the other team that's up
yeah they said five people died on their side well our tired
team got wiped out we didn't even get a single we didn't we
only got five i think i got to shoot my gun twice i was just
i was scared i was scared i was gonna shoot my own teammates
i was so fucking scared everybody was just like in my face
if that zone pulled the middle it would have been so much
different i feel like yeah that would have been a lot wasn't
there a map where you can turn off zones why didn't we do
yeah you can't there is a way to like it where you can turn
on zones and just like everybody meets up in one spot and
just battles it out i feel like why didn't we just do that
instead of letting instead of letting them have all of this
all right who are we playing who are we playing we need a
new castle i think i feel like a new castle is very helpful
here oh yeah oh that means three strikes so it's newcastle
uh maybe conduit conduit horizon newcastle conduit horizon
last time last time i played the last one i just died off
rip because literally like we didn't have any kind of
character that we could fight with yeah wait what what did
you play last time we were playing conduit newcastle and
caustic it was that okay so we just don't have caustic then
we should have like someone i'm gonna play horizon i can do
conduit or newcastle which one do you prefer sage um
i don't think she wants either or no i like oh are you
saying like of those two which one what i prefer which one i
would want to be yeah which one you want to play like which
one are you more comfortable i'm a condo with me and oh yeah
i'll just play newcastle okay and this time i'll use my
shield i was on a team with timmy for the the no strikes
three strikes or something and then and then he kept yelling
shield but i thought he meant conduit shield so i'd never he
was like shield shield shield and i looked at my condo i was
like where the fucks the shield and then but he meant me he
was talking to me and I was like oh and then we died son I
didn't understand like where was the Newcastle shield I was
like oh you were talking to me because he's after shield he
said Q so I looked at my condo I was like give me the Q no
you're so real like yeah where is it oh my gosh so if you so
if you want me to use my Newcastle shield please say
Newcastle before she knows it.
You need to be specific.
I feel a little bit better.
Alright, make sure you're not on fuse.
I'll be on Newcastle.
Watson mains are like eating this journey.
For real.
I mean, the next round is...
it's uh the next round is punching again so yeah i hope
somebody plays crypto this time i think that's what's gonna
happen folks a good choice too
wait where are we dropping do we even call zone we didn't
even call but i feel i think we can go um i don't even know
what's gonna be free maybe oracle i have no idea i didn't
even check
I don't know, don't know.
And I'm on 130 ping.
Are y'all on high ping?
Nope.
Oh, wait, yes.
160.
What the fuck?
This is not even East Coast anymore.
We're on Tokyo.
No, we're on Europe.
I get 100 ping on Tokyo.
This is Europe.
Wait, what the hell?
Do you want to go, like, way back here?
Just go wherever.
Yeah, just go wherever.
What the fuck?
All right, this is about to be really bad, then.
I'm on 150 ping on her.
I think there's one person coming here.
I'm pretty sure that, yeah, there is a team going.
We're getting conned.
Do you want to go here or do you want to go like here?
And then like we can go to acres.
There's a team in acres though.
Oh, oh, okay.
Just go to the compound.
Just go to the compound that you ping.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, no balls.
You don't want to con them.
We have three strikes.
Yeah, my flying was kind of...
Yeah, I apologize.
I was looking around too much trying to figure out where the
hell was going.
I'm going, I'm going, my ping's going up.
Oh, okay, match editor.
Thank fucking God.
Okay, I was gonna say, how was my ping going higher?
I was gonna, I was gonna.
I was gonna.
I was just on fucking Brazil servers or something.
We're in, we're in fucking Sao Paulo?
We're in Sao Paulo?
Lauren?
Oh my God, back in rank, we go.
All right.
Oh, someone was on Lifeline.
Yeah.
it's like nobody on horizon this time it's a lot of i'm
seeing a lot of newcastle condo acostic actually oh it reset
to london okay yeah i was like yeah i knew it i knew it was
eu i was like this is eu ping there's no fucking way there's
no fucking way everybody's on condo acostic and watson yeah
that sounds about right yeah i mean that worked out
we're seeing strats from other people wait someone has
mirage who's that genius what the is cooking right now it's
that uh temper guy oh my god i don't think giggle got it
like into play i think they started without it's okay
hey round two now we're definitely not in london
okay how good are your zone reads
well of course you the fucking pro player that had that's
rank one like i'm not a pro player a sparring pro player i
just got here i just got to pc like two months ago they're
being called a pro player again uh i'm not bad at reading
zones i'm not horrible at it okay but like if you had what
is your position in your team the roller player yeah yeah I
had a feeling the one I'm the one I could show I played
blood him Hey Are y'all both on him and gay?
Yes.
Yeah Absolutely Of course.
I'm just a content creator.
I haven't shot I haven't shot my brother like that part
every single game I've barely gotten to see my gun.
I feel like I'm dead.
What the fuck bro.
You're giving me so much hope right now for our team I'm
completely and totally ready.
You're supposed to hype us up.
What the fuck happened?
You barely shot your gun.
I'm ready to drop like a 6K because I'm ready to drop a 6K.
But this is the game that's going to change.
You are so warmed up with the zero kills, man.
You're so...
Bro, I had a kill before you had a kill.
And I'm the content creator.
Bro, what's up?
What's going on?
You got rank one.
What happened?
Did you fall off?
No, I'm not falling off.
Did you?
Don't worry.
This is the game that's going to change, right?
This is it.
I got zero damage in the duos game, but that makes you feel
anybody.
We got placed eighth, though.
Yeah, I got last place in the duos because dropped us AFK
getting chicken and rice.
So we had zero plaque.
way he he went and get chicken and rice and i asked him if
it was worth it and he said yeah oh no as long as it was
worth it i guess we still got a hundred dollars out of
chicken and rice so okay period i love that yeah last place
still gets a hundred that's all that matters
don't worry i believe this is it 12 you're gonna you're
gonna frag out here you've like you've like stored all your
fracking energy for this one game because after this game
you're just gonna be punching people this is your last
chance to shoot your gun oh that's true yeah this is the
actual last chance to shoot the gun
got this easy peasy also how's the switch from console to pc
i think he like afk to cry
no no no we went to go get some some snack
yeah he's just on a snack break he's just on a snack break
guys it's okay he's not he's not gonna he's off to get his
own chicken and rice chat He's off to get his own chicken
and rice
We got this easy peasy I believe in our team We can't get
worse
Alright Maybe pick the right character He did Wait are you
actually still here?
Who else?
No I'm pretty sure he's actually not Like actually gone?
I think it's AFK Okay if he's in the bathroom that long i
don't think he's okay i don't yeah wash washing hands i
don't think he's okay if he's in the bathroom that long
there it is okay we're in the right area now let's hope that
he's not jump master oh thank god okay because i'm pretty
sure he's still afk
i'm scared where are we supposed to land i don't know now
now i don't know he's the afk we couldn't check oh you have
terrible luck just like because how is two teammates go afk
oh my god i really don't know where to go i think we
probably should just land right here we're going back we're
repeating this i mean we we have a teammate that's afk i
don't know what the is yeah like i don't want to like i
don't want to contest anywhere where i know people are going
to be at i don't think it's a coincidence anymore two
teammates that are afk no well split off are you back yeah
i'm back oh shit what happened to you huh where did you go
nowhere we were talking to you you didn't talk to us talking
to chat oh my god you didn't even even the fucking answer
back to us we had important questions about this game we
were metacrafting We're theory crafting!
Hmm.
Oh, but I did ask you how you feel about switching from
console to PC.
It's good.
It feels better.
More crisp.
More responsive.
That's good.
I've got a lot of cool people.
They got a little car right there.
I'm gonna grab this.
Uh...
I want to go try to fight the team at orbital low-key.
Y 'all got guns?
Yeah, I did.
I'm down to fight.
I'm okay to fight.
All right, let's walk up and hope we're okay.
Did I see them?
On me.
Literally on my roof.
Oh, okay.
I'm here now.
Oh, my gosh.
Why don't we chop them aside?
Newcastle's week.
Wait, there's a...
There's team on...
There's a...
There's a third on the roof.
I'm going to fucking ape this guy.
I'm going to ape this guy over here.
Yeah, I'm inside the building.
I don't see anybody.
to our yeah he's by himself i don't know i don't have to put
it on him nice nice oh my god you did it you got the kill
congratulations i'm so proud of you this is the game that's
gonna turn around i knew it i got the shield upgrade uses
one i have q and two i'm just gonna wait for it they're both
up here yeah They jumped down.
You gotta wipe this so they can get our fucking get their
loop.
It's just two.
Are they in the building?
Yeah, they're inside here.
Okay, we can go through this other door then.
Y'all drop through that door.
Yeah, I'm going through that door.
I'm going in.
I'm going in now.
That's my nade.
Oh, no.
He blocked it.
He was almost cracked again.
Hit 50 on blue.
That's mine.
I'm going in.
He's on the other side.
Knock, knock, knock, knock.
Dead, dead.
Nice.
Hey!
Easy!
You see nothing to worry about.
We need to make sure they don't drop back on us.
They might land on us.
Yeah, I'm trying to get the loot back.
I do kind of want a better light gun.
So if you see like a R9 or 301.
K2, I have an RE.
Which isn't the best.
I dropped a purple energy mag.
It's a havoc here if anyone wants that.
Oh, no, thank you.
Nope.
What do you think zone's gonna end?
I can't read zones at all.
It's gonna pull back the phase driver, Bonza.
It's probably gonna hard pull back to fucking phase driver
back here.
Yeah, so we should head over now just to grab a spot.
Yeah, possibly.
See if we can, yeah.
I grabbed in Alt Excel for us.
Yeah, ping me any...
Sage and I need light guns.
Better light guns, so we find any.
There's an R9 in one of those boxes.
There is?
Oh, I'll go.
Is it from the horizon you killed or...
Yeah, it's the horizon box.
It's like right there, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, you caught all the way there?
Unless it, like, is gone now.
Yeah, it's gone.
Yeah, no worries.
We'll find something.
They're fighting in front of us at this show.
They're poking.
I don't know if they're fighting.
I feel like you should just get like a spot because like
kills don't really matter to us Yeah, I'm just getting
people out in the end.
They're just gonna It's just gonna like What is it lock up
the The respawn anyway by that by then?
Is someone No, okay, I thought it was a car.
It's even Icarus.
I saw that landed in there
Uh, take this blue knot Oh, wait, I should Just kidding.
Right here.
I'm ready.
Right in front of us right there.
Just land on the building right here.
Right here.
We can shoot this kid in the back.
I'm shooting.
Cracked one.
I cracked one.
I'm getting on the building.
Oh my god, what happened to my?
I got you two.
I'm batting, I'm batting, batting, batting, batting.
Yeah, you're here.
There's somebody over here.
Over here.
The last guy is over here.
The last guy's over here.
Right here.
Maybe I'll try to kill him if y'all can.
Oh, he's kind of...
I don't know.
I have the jitter bug.
I have that bug.
He ran ran.
I can't get him.
Yeah.
You can come back.
I think he's just gonna wait for them to crawl back to them.
Yeah.
But there's this other team right here.
I don't want to, like, separate too much.
I think...
I feel like I should get knocked and you guys should res me.
No, no, no, no.
I don't want them to, like, int.
Yeah, but okay, I'll just full heal then where are the
bodies that we killed because they're just gonna crawl to
them They're just crawling towards them
Okay, I mean what the fuck is the stone pool
We still play left side of Icarus over here back here if we
can how many baths y'all have oh I have two I have two
I think there might be a team still in here, so be careful.
Yeah, oh my god Oh, just right here, where they were before.
Yeah, can you call me?
I'm going to get right behind here.
I don't know if I can get to you before.
I'm going to get to Wells, actually, maybe.
Yeah, he's looking at me right now.
Oh, no.
Can you ult us?
Just ult us.
No, I don't have all.
I don't have all used already.
That's why, yeah.
I didn't have all.
He's pushing.
Mirage, pushing.
He's behind his box.
I think?
Because I see a...
I'm calling back.
Oh.
Probably bat.
I don't have Q yet.
I'm batting.
I'm just throwing these.
Uh, 14.
Rotate through.
Yeah, that's a, that's a team that we knocked earlier in the
past.
Gonna grab something.
Team at this building.
There's a classic team in here.
I have Q.
I have Alt here.
They're just sitting in the building.
like no frames right now whoa out 88 your castle one i'm
going i'm going i'm going i'm going one one one one one hold
that full dead full dead full dead all right we're gonna
here i'm gonna raise i'm gonna make it i'm grabbing this r9
okay go i want those shits i have a the fucking that jitter
bug my body is like shaking like i can't not good um i had
it too for a moment i don't know what it is my frames are
really bad right now too my frames are really bad too like i
have like 80 frames i was about to say flames i'm okay don't
worry you're gonna have to kill everybody don't worry i can
clutch this for us you got it i'm leaving you i need like um
let's see oh it says you have a purple knockdown i need that
Okay.
Oh yeah, I'm like, oh, it's like only in that spot.
I'm like jittering really bad.
Okay, I dropped the blue for us.
I'm already close.
I wonder if I can reset my game.
I don't know.
It's risky.
I mean, I like, I'm fucking shaking all over the place.
It might be, it might just be because we're on the edge of
the map.
Like the closer I get like.
No, it's been the whole game.
It's been the whole game.
For you?
Okay.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
Just do it now.
Might as well.
It's fine.
If you can do it now, then...
I just don't want to...
This is not getting back into the game.
Okay, that's fair.
We got to rotate.
Hey.
Sometimes you can join back.
Sometimes you can't.
We're just going to play underneath here.
We just hold everybody out.
If there's not a team here, there's a team here, actually.
So Watson, Newcastle team, all left side right there.
Okay.
I'm going to try to fight them, try to get them off of it.
I do have all up.
I also have all up, but...
Newcastle 1, Newcastle 1.
Oh, there you are.
Hold on.
here then we're all tough right we have to because of this
oh they just called it oh no i might be dead to this maybe
i'm fine i'm fine fine for now okay you're gonna shoot me oh
the need yeah
yeah this is bad i might die to oh wait i'm just gonna keep
spam pressing try to spam yeah i'm going for it i'm gonna
die they're pushing right here
yeah a Cossacks one shot I'm just gonna try to spell I can't
freaking see anything oh I can't I got knocked here I think
with this we just have to nice play songs can good job nice
I think you might be able to get a rat res yeah oh no good
shot oh I got knocked with it oh wrong person sorry right to
the right got us they're just focusing us they're not
shooting that team at all yeah it's okay we had two more
strikes we just got we can rotate to a better position yeah
trying to figure out what a better position would be do you
want to try up here or no or like like like i don't have
okay i'm gonna look inside i'm gonna there's a full team
inside i have a queue behind us i'm a Should we come down?
I'm gonna come down to you.
I'm shooting on this team, it's like so hard.
I knocked one and shot another team is looking at us right
now.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
They res it.
Yeah, I mean, we might be able to rotate backside this way.
I see, I'm getting shot from the other team.
I don't have two, sorry.
Yeah, it's fine.
We can just cue me back up.
I mean, like, can...
Yeah.
team right here jump underneath there's nobody underneath
sitch i'm dead i fell through a hole oh can you get
underneath yeah i'm getting i'm under i'm under it's fine
there's a shooting right here right here there's a person
right here in the like they're right here underneath i think
you get the rest chilling it's a fuse nice nice oh i'm
trying to shield i'm trying to shield it
i don't know where they are oh they dropped down to the
right they're right here
I mean, there's nothing I can do.
Yeah, they're hard pushing now.
Oh!
Nice try.
It's hard.
It's like having to drop when everyone's already like in
fucking buildings is rough.
Like this is what makes it like so annoying.
Where do we do it?
I'm trying to look.
Um...
Is anybody in height?
There's a team on height.
Do you want to try like on the wall right there?
Just land here, just land here, land here, let me land here,
me.
Just like try to ANK here at this corner.
Try AFK in this corner.
Try to AFK in a corner.
Yeah I'm trying.
They're, they're inting.
No they can't jump down.
Those fucking get fried.
just AFK in a corner.
Literally say AFK in this corner right here.
I, i'm in a different corner, but Hey climb up when you can
just AFK here.
Oh!
There's a team on the right.
Just literally don't make any noise.
Don't show any to sign a life here.
Just living here.
This is our home.
All these fucking sky naves.
They don't have a Watson above us, I'm pretty sure.
I think they do.
I hear a bunch of... Yeah, I hear a bunch of...
There was a fence up there earlier, so I thought maybe.
How long until our ults, by the way?
50.
I'm at 50.
Yeah, I'm at 52.
Look at her knees right here.
Tommy, I'm just dead.
Oh my god.
I got you?
I got you You got a Newcastle wall.
You got a Newcastle wall if you have it.
Yeah.
I got it.
Oh, dude.
There's, yeah, there's just people down here I fell.
Oh my god.
What?
It's just so much.
Oh, it's just like two, three teams sitting right there.
There's so many people.
They all shot us.
Yeah, that was dead.
Oh, we were fucked.
There was no way we're going to get to zone.
There was no way.
Yeah, that's rough.
We were not even close to zone.
All right, nice try.
Gee, cheese.
See you guys in the next one.
Gee, cheese, gee cheese.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit, that zone pull was actually crazy.
We were not even, like, gonna...
We were not even gonna fucking...
We're so far!
This is where the zone landed onto!
We were here!
How will we travel?
How are we gonna travel all the way?
Jeez!
Yeah, that was...
That was insane.
That was actually...
early chat we we actually peaked early we like everybody
aiming at yes everybody shot at us holy fuck there was no
way to live there was that poor man that poor man got oh my
god a poor man got destroyed I didn't forget to queue this
time yeah I remember to queue this tab yeah i shot my gun we
all shot our gun thank god
there was actually like no way to play everyone really what
what the fuck was that sound what the fuck was that gun
sound no more now no more gun now is back to fisting chat
we're back I was getting too much money.
It was getting too good for too long.
I was getting way too much money.
Yeah, that was a very weird energy gun sound.
My guy.
True.
Next one is LG, by the way, chat.
The next one is LG.
Okay, I hope...
This is fucked up to say.
Um
Wait, I think they Oh my god Oh my god I hope Timmy doesn't
place higher so So like I would be the best team they had No
that's I'm joking I'm joking No he's gonna place higher He's
gonna win I'm fucking I bet you he's gonna win He literally
has deeds He literally has deeds Like on his team Like
they're set They're actually set Idiots an eva a bro where
was i left there to be fair i didn't fucking i didn't
fucking cue that's my luck that's his luck bro he literally
has d's that's fucking crazy he literally has d's on his
team that's insane he got fifth yes he was no their team was
no better than my our team
they got fifth we're the same we're the same you think about
it we're we're we're the same we're our team is the same it
didn't matter our team won't we we both when I was on
Timmy's team we also placed a fifth Timmy, when Timmy is not
on my team, he also plays fifth, so it didn't matter.
It actually did not matter.
It's the same.
My sportsmanship is off the roof.
I hope Dwells didn't take my banter as too harsh.
I hope he actually didn't get angry.
This one's trying to lighten the mood.
I'll be real as it was just some friendly banter.
I hope I didn't make him cry.
Wait, wait.
He hates VTubers now.
Join the club.
Join the fucking club.
We're playing Apex here.
Normies don't know what to do.
Okay, let's see.
What's our last team?
All right, our last team is...
Oh, we got Naughty again.
And we got Sage.
What is this rat?
This is not random.
I get the same teammates all the time.
I swear.
I literally got Sage and Naughty for this is not random this
is this is not where is the variation here
i literally played with naughty and i just played with sage
last game how is this random a spotify shuffle to be like
yeah has rigged this for me in what way he rated the
opposite that right if it was rigged i would be on the
winning team
if this was rigged i would have been on control i would have
been on fucking control and on the other side i would not
been an assault character
All right, let's see.
We new code.
New code.
Where's the new code?
Here we go.
All right, new code time.
New code.
What did I play last time?
Watson, right?
Yeah, I was on Watson.
Watson.
Okay.
I didn't leak the code like last.
I didn't leak the code like Hal did.
uh i was hoping they were there first so i can just join off
of them but they weren't so i need to fucking look up the
leaderboard shit again uh let's see team 14 team 14
all right let's see let me get my bookie up just in case
can't believe it can't believe it what happened to meeting
new people but not too many new not too many new people
though I like to meet new people gradually like two at a
time meeting new people I can't believe I can't believe I
got the same teammates what are the odds like I feel like
almost every game I met like the like one of the person one
person would be the person I played with last game
tempo gave me a head start with jen and timmy and said
you're on your own and then after that he's like now it's
real random basically one and two people at a time hey but
it's cool it was great that we got to play with timmy and
jen though and and like
the the one minute drop was like the peak there for me that
was with the chicken and rice that was peak right there
chicken and rice there we go uh hello hello again sage hello
hello again naughty hello i can't believe i've been playing
with the same people all day it's not random it's not random
they're just putting his back to back with people i refuse
to is random right yeah i think it's like just i don't even
know just like either crazy luck or bro but then how did
some teams get like all the pros how does that what the fuck
at least like when you're random you'll be like wait this is
this is a luck fair let me just move them a little bit like
like what the fuck timmy and deeds on the same team on a
game mode where you actually shoot the gun i got jen on my
first game but he does we don't shoot our guns because we're
fisting people like we got another no gun here this one yeah
crazy i'm gonna so pros okay are you the guy that knows
zones are you the zone guy for your team uh i know zones you
know somewhat okay the zones we've been playing today have
been crazy oh yeah no they're terrible yeah they've been so
bad they're like hard to guess too but yeah we should we
should get a good guess here did you call your call your pli
yet yeah yeah down beast all right nice okay yep yep we got
damn i'm i'm on watson oh watson yep you got watson um and
then i'll play valc and then if you want to play lifeline
sage yeah or would you rather i actually play lifeline okay
do you not think that's a i yeah yeah it's fine okay also is
there a slight echo maybe yeah yeah no it's not on not easy
there's an echo sorry about that no it's okay i was like
maybe i'm just really listening to myself i don't know okay
that's my maybe somebody this time is gonna play crypto
after the lessons we've learned on the first game maybe
someone will actually play crypto this time i believe i i
believe Wait, what's the lifeline for?
Oh, for the self-revive.
I took my headphones out.
So if you're talking, I can't hear you.
Wait, but would it matter though for self-revive?
Because we're all just going to fucking be in the mosh pit
in the end.
Oh, I mean, yeah.
It'll definitely get you some extra placements, though.
You know, just like...
Because you still have to get thirsted as lifeline if you
get knocked.
But at the same time, you might be right regarding that.
Because there's so many fences.
But if there's a crypto, lifeline's so good.
Like if crypto blows up.
everything up takes all the fences out oh okay okay yeah i
was just thinking like uh i was just thinking like oh man
are we will she even survive long enough to yeah it's kind
of honestly maybe like a wraith instead of lifeline i don't
know or like caustic caustic was really good for my first
game or your no punch yeah yeah no punch because we just had
the gas cans to like make them knock like you know take some
extra damage yeah i mean uh with like gens and stuff it's
it's hard to do that that's true at the end zone yeah that's
true yeah but like at the same time like it also kills don't
really matter you know but like yeah again it is only flesh
damage it's just like spacing spacing wise yeah i mean wass
like insane to like spam fences around because like and
people can't shoot your gen you know you can literally play
wherever yeah you could play like in the wide open like
everyone looking at you all right so are you gonna do life
on our race then for sage um that's a good question you made
a good point because i i think valk will be really good yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then uh i think watson and valk 100 and
then
What do you think, Sage?
Sage Doc?
Do you think like Wraith Portal stuff or...
Lifeline?
Boy, I think Sage is AFK.
I think she's AFK.
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll wait for Sage to get back and hear and- We've
got plenty of time.
Yeah.
We've got plenty of time to theory craft.
Right.
how well have your games been so decent middle of the pack
you know how about you pack uh i think i got like two top
fives in the beginning and then i peaked and then um i
peaked very early on uh and then ever ever since then it's
not been great ever since then tempo has definitely rigged
it against me yeah putting us in in the assault category oh
that yeah that was horrible i think that was the turn my
turning point was when dropped afk for duos and and then i
got ratted out and instantly no way he had to go afk he was
he was getting his chicken and rice he was getting his
dinner and then and then i i got i walked up did not see a
full team in front of me and Hi!
Oh my gosh.
That stinks.
Oh, is everybody waiting for me?
No, that's not it.
Where am I?
No, I'm not.
I was on the game.
No, what the fuck?
I was already in Team 14.
What?
Did they say something to you?
My chat was like, they're waiting for you.
And I was like, what?
I didn't even realize.
I didn't even see that.
I wasn't even in Team 5.
I'm not even the last person.
There's a Team 5.
do
we claim down beast already yeah yep we got it okay i
believe uncontested let me double all right nice okay we're
john oh they forced moved me all right but i still wasn't
the last person i wasn't holding it up they were people
design full and gen gun okay it's all right there it's
fisting around so it doesn't matter it's like what the is
team six i think they're actually though actually they won't
be on it yet hello did you say um so yes to lifeline was
there anything else you talked oh yeah if you want to do
lifeline or race which would you prefer um probably race
okay i'm not a child but if you but if you want to be yeah
she could queue she could save her queue for the final zone
yeah like that could be a whole other thing too yeah it's
sort of like up in the air with like if lifeline self-revive
or race like portal will stall longer than the other like if
she gets knocked out outside a zone when it's tiny then like
that'd be fucked for her and yeah yeah i just like if
there's a crypto that would be good for us but because that
would like help everyone sort of yeah i'm pretty sure it
would actually help the entire one must go there must be
somebody on the enemy team that's gonna go crypto there's no
way after what happened in the first game i i refuse to
believe no one's gonna go crypto yeah unless everyone's same
thing we are and we're like yeah there's gonna be someone
that's crypto totally and it has to be but there's like so
many of us here there's so many there's no way one person's
not going to pick crypto we just need one guy we literally
need one guy to crypto out oh spikes would be good actually
oh what about catalyst with cat spikes someone just
mentioned that my chat catalyst with cat spikes and like
like final final like final yeah but when does it watch
doesn't watch it does watson all eat it or no uh yeah it
does i think so it's just too close yeah watson okay i
almost i couldn't find your honor you already i'm watson
you're chilling oh nice thank god i don't know i feel like
watson all eats the cat list stuff right yeah you're right
yeah it does game doesn't matter because like we had a fuse
and it didn't matter because there were so many thought
about that too because we had a fuse too we were like fuse
what were we fuse watson lifeline i think actually yeah i
think the the fuse alt doesn't get eight by watson general
unless i'm tripping i think that's why people are trying to
fuse and we're not beast by the way all right um okay here
we go ready now we go i'm so bad with yeah you might want to
take you might want to take off from me i'm really bad with
landing oh no you're chilling you're yeah there's no way
they saw naughty's game on there and they're like we
wouldn't contest him yeah i'm not punching him yeah they're
like oh fuck it's notting here i'll land i'll land far one
of you guys can land like close i'll grab the other side of
down beast or grab inside down beast yep that's perfect okay
so you can have the outside the crust yeah
where are people right here oh they're right here right here
oh they have the car they just grab that car that's fine we
don't need it yeah we'll be chilling we're gonna be looking
around for caches and stuff it's okay wait actually maybe we
do need it i might get this car over here i'm not gonna lie
oh wait three right next to each other that's so pretty i
like subconsciously picked up guns because we were shooting
yeah i got like really excited when i saw the vault um yes
we're getting this car we're chilling you have a car yeah i
got the middle car okay i got an evac if anyone wants this
yeah oh my god i just yeah you can't even take guns my
shield cells okay all right ulti cells are huge in this one
too all right i have no ulti cells i'm gonna carry all of
them also gonna make sure we have this car oh wait what do i
need this for yeah make sure nobody steals it there's all
lot of thermites and stuff here isn't there evac if anyone
wants it okay i already have an evac let's definitely start
going for caches sooner than later there's an individual oh
they're stealing it no cash person i could probably punch
them out it's they're by themselves i mean caches are
forever yeah get out of here oh never mind it's too oh it's
okay just if you get punched out we yeah i'm coming over are
they chasing me oh they are yeah they're actually chasing me
what the fuck freaks what are these freaks doing don't worry
oh my gosh so many needs we're here we're here these guys
are actually trying to 3v3 us get out no no they're not get
out get out they're broke okay i'm grabbing the car there's
a thermite on it i don't know if it's if it's theirs or mine
right this one right this one all right i got the car i got
the car i got the car i got the car oh he's just real quick
punch him punch him out punch him out nice that was a good
art star stick nice let's go thank you that is huge nice we
should guide it wait wait i'm gonna guide i'm gonna guide it
with my fences oh yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna guide it watch
that barrel all right oh goodness they want their buddies
back that is free evo punch right there want their guard
buddy back that's good i use all my nades they got a gift
through this fence oh my gosh no they really try to steal
the car that's so funny are they still here oh this game is
so enhanced it might be they might be wait we grab that
phoenix gift they took the cannon right yeah they could take
the cannon they might come back right now we should go
that's fine that's fine armor stuff though we can drive
we're doing that Okay.
You can do the ring too for extra.
Oh, sorry.
I'm in.
No, you're good.
I need some nades too, so I'm just trying to like move a
little more.
Okay.
And then we'll do like a ring console nades and stuff.
My fences are still there.
So like, I don't know, maybe they're crafting him back.
Maybe.
Oh, they're bringing him back.
Oh, yeah, they could.
Oh, wait, they brought him back.
Yeah, they did.
I'm bringing them.
No way.
Where are they?
Oh.
They're right here.
Oh, they took it back.
I'm about to punch design.
He's not laying on the cannon.
Oh, they ulted.
He ulted.
Back out.
Come back, come back.
Come back.
Backing out.
Get the car.
No, we got the car.
Again!
No!
Oh, they went through the car.
I'm going up to the car.
They took the car.
No.
He actually has a car.
I can't believe it.
He, they actually, we got baited.
All right, we're gonna let him go.
We'll let him go.
Yeah, we should.
Yeah, yeah, we should grab.
No, I feel like we really should grab, do like more armor.
Oh my God.
My heart sank.
I thought that was a different team coming in.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go get this cache here.
Ignore this.
What is this portal?
It's a beautiful one.
It was in your honor, actually.
Yeah, I want to grab some armor cache.
We'll take this Evac and then go get this cache up top.
I can't believe they actually did it.
Probably go that way.
No, that was a good play.
I'm not gonna lie.
I didn't even think about Bringing the card back close to
them.
No, yeah.
Oh my god.
If I had another arc, he's not getting in that though.
Yeah, I know.
Same.
I didn't have any other.
I had only nades in.
I only had nades in Thermite.
The madman.
Zion is tripping for that.
No, that was funny.
I'm going to go to the ring console.
Yep, yep.
You can get that.
Go for it right behind you.
We'll go to this console.
then that package is probably taken or it's not taking out
what the heck nice what's that cash out of it maybe whoa
it's looking right what's it looking right there's a one oh
it only tells it again oh i forgot i put a people people up
here all right let me know they're coming over i have a i
have a ring around me okay yeah it's okay no you're good
you're good all right i got it we'll hit this again as well
in 20 seconds question i dropped a name if you guys want one
okay i think up there on the tippity top of the building
that you're you just went over yeah i'm leaving i'm leaving
out it's just her on the roof though hit the speaking again
hit the speaking again for the zone oh she's coming down
she's right here hey come back come back actually maybe i'm
tripping where does she go oh she's oh she yeah she's gone
she was solo solo della oh she was serious we should go grab
this army yep let's get this one okay let's let's save that
evac actually you know pop it pop the back up here i'm gonna
debate i mean i can't fly back i have to take this fucking
zip you're john we'll call our ebeck up top here and there's
fly on that and then we'll go through to wall we should get
far from up here Wait, so did she actually open that?
Yeah.
You want to put it here?
Oh, let's put on this roof.
I think this is the only way to do it.
To get over this checkpoint stuff.
Here you go.
And then we do want to get that one too.
I think we grab this one first and this choke and then get
this one.
So we're all in purple.
We just fly this way.
Nice.
Perfect.
Yay, we lived.
I could uh meet you guys too back like here if you want to
like show around here oh not like full split but I'm just
grabbing this cash we'll just like start our way over there
oh I'm gonna grab this other cash too yeah grab this guy
yeah yeah we should split up there that's okay yeah I'm on
the way to you guys now I got my kunai on me grabbing the
other cash which way are we going uh we're gonna to try and
get into a spot it's gonna pull it back here it has to be
right yeah probably it's gonna definitely pull back there i
mean we can literally play anything like just next to
somebody now wait so what's fast phase attack phase faster
like you're like the the little uh time sign you do i guess
the phrasing like we try to see if there's people up here uh
yeah i'm gonna i feel like the yeah the rate definitely
should yeah all right yeah i got you go up there i believe
in you
there's another evac i have another evac okay nice it's huge
is it good safe yeah it's super safe oh i can fence this
yeah fence this and then people can't even get up here just
like a little fence here but we're gonna keep going we're
gonna try and get like inside uh they are throwing needs
right here though okay all right we're gonna literally just
run up on the bridge just play up top you gotta wait for
doki though i'm here yeah the watson we're just and there's
a team right here too okay so there's a team like in the
middle and there's a team right there looks like yep just
run up to me we're just gonna run up to me we're just i knew
we're safe there's a crypto we're so safe that is awesome
that is huge oh my god that's so huge for us yep that's fine
kind of me kind of me we got to be like on doki i get ready
the gym somewhere i'll tell you where probably right in this
corner there's a team here is right here yeah yeah actually
put put it here put it here put it here put it here yeah all
right i just get a bunch of fences this is our zone now okay
we make our our box now yep oh my gosh is that the cat is
that them that's further than us how far are you from purple
doki um 143 okay you want to just punch these people try and
get it no way no way and that didn't EMP there's no way no
way there come over here sage let's just like chill here
without any dang she slapped the hell out of me I'm so sorry
wait this EMP this car didn't break no it didn't it didn't
reach all the way over there it stopped like right here at
this box so that was really ridiculous no way I can't
believe it
our zone yeah the team just landed right on top of us yep
yeah i have all in 34.
this team just hit the beacon i'm gonna see where they go
okay they're just chilling there i love it it's a good time
cool here yeah okay we have all this space we should be fine
yep whoo here you want a phoenix They're just fist fighting.
Wait, they're fighting right now.
They stole their car!
No way.
Do you want to get... Do you want to hit them?
Do you want to punch in?
Do you want to get your purple?
Bro, I can't fucking do this.
Wait, I think that this is your fence.
That's your fence.
Oh, it is your fence.
It is?
Oh, it is!
I can't tell!
You're like, uh...
Yeah, there's so many fences.
I just saw red.
Oh my god, they took back the car!
Holy shit.
Shit.
Here, come put two like four fences here, you know what I
mean?
Like put him across.
Make like a box here.
Is that designing it?
It is.
Yeah, yeah, put like make us a box right here.
Just like a...
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, they did something here.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Fuck off.
There we go.
Put like one in each corner here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Make a little square.
Yeah.
a little square perfect all right are we staying under here
then oh yeah yeah okay this is ours now oh fuck off oh
design is trying to kidnap you back up back up up oh oh my
gosh oh that's a good strat let's make a kidnap thing yeah
all right put four fences and like he's not happy oh my god
oh you went through yeah you're gonna have to come back yeah
i don't have fences here nice right back good that was great
you not abby there's another team right here he's so weird
design is so weird why did he mad oh oh that's bad cue right
away cue right away cue after you said that oh it's a portal
after you said that too whoa oh my gosh my discord crashed
what the fuck oh my discord crashed was trying to tell you
to put fences where did you want me to put it here put four
fences in us in a little like diagonal thing so put one
right here okay and one corner and then one diagonal of it
and then one like right here and then connect the two
diagonal ones
and then put one here wait hold on to pick this one up right
here this one okay i'm like confusing you yeah yeah yeah
yeah put one fence put like in like a smaller square we're
gonna wait actually you know what we should move for the
zone i think oh yeah come over here come over here come to
me come to me you jen yeah yeah yeah yeah hold on i'm gonna
see if up here's better here come up to me climb up to me
all right oh hello guys i got that car climb up and then put
your put your jen right here why don't you just oh it's here
now right here right here we're punching everyone whoa oh my
god this is our new spot are you okay are you okay no they
like ran me over with the car i couldn't move they were
trying to trap you with the car oh my god back up yeah we're
punching everybody off of us here all right our spot now
this is like my mode this is all i'm good at in this game
actually okay but what oh they have a gen you could actually
fence their car if you I need to have my gen up now.
I can't get over here.
I'm 105 off evo.
We don't have any ulti cells, right guys?
No, no, no ulti.
I didn't find any.
Okay, let me know when you get your gen, Doki.
Okay, I have a 27%.
Yep, yep.
Try and punch people for your evo if you can, too.
I'm trying.
I'm punching this random guy.
When you just punched in the car, I should do something?
Yeah.
No way.
55.
Punching the car.
getting my armor my five percent armor from the car oh my
gosh bro slowly and surely this is crazy i got it i got it i
got it i got it nice nice good job two pylons okay perfect
perfect oh you do you need a syringe no i'm oh wait yeah i'm
gonna syringe i'm gonna pop orange pop orange because of the
caustics gonna fight the car yeah and then in the in the
final endgame doki, you're just going to like spam fences
everywhere, and then just like try and you know, connect
them all, get them down like the ends on.
We're fine, we're fine.
Oh my god, this is not fine.
I don't know actually.
Are you okay?
I don't even know how many fences.
Okay, yeah, I have I think I have maximum.
Oh, we have a nice spot.
Let's go.
I have the maximum amount of fences.
Oh my god, they destroyed my fences!
That's fucked up.
And that's why you're stunned.
Look at you.
Oh, God.
My fences.
They are.
They do not like your fences.
Wait, Doki, can you put some fences here?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From up top.
Just put like, like a bunch down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just slowly coming up to us.
I do.
They are actually trying to push us.
They're just slowly walking up.
I'm scared.
Oh, this team here too is like, but that Watson looks like
she's panicking, so I think it's okay.
Yeah, make sure you have like all 12 fences down around,
like everywhere.
Bro, stop.
You're stealing our fences.
Oh, they broke the gen.
They broke our gen.
I have gen.
You want me to put it right here.
Come put gen on me.
me right here oh yeah yeah wait actually hold it hold it
hold it hold it hold it hold your gen hold your gen right
here oh i have to heal you guys okay yeah yeah i'm okay i'm
okay this caustic oh this team right here right here put
your gen down put your gen down we have to i'm putting i'm
putting i'm putting i might die i'm gonna die whoa someone
threw their ult on me i'm dead no i'm dead i'm dead they
threw yeah it's up to you daddy you gotta live there was too
many why did the There's no way I'm getting hushed.
Oh, you have the chance!
I am impressed the crypto saved the alt for that long.
That, oh, no way.
I can't believe design headbutted me.
He took the time to be head by me.
You know what?
This is crazy.
Now the crypto alt's, oh my god.
Oh my gosh, you could totally respawn us.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you could totally do it.
Yeah, the worst of...
Oh, my God, they were...
There's actually a lot of cryptos now.
That's crazy.
There were so many cryptos, but yet nobody crypto alted?
How the fuck was that?
They did not care.
That really sucks.
Yeah, that caustic was just...
Yeah, that caustic was so clutch.
I'm surprised that no one fucking...
I'm surprised that no Watsonall ate that caustic.
alt yeah yeah i didn't think it was one that was in between
three different watson alts how is that possible that's okay
not last though you'll be 19th and you die that's fine look
at all the emps going off over there oh my god that is crazy
we should have if only we didn't lose our car wait do you
have your oh you have a redeploy or no uh i i'm in a balcony
yeah yeah okay oh my god look at this it's gonna be hard to
get it off but i'm gonna try i gotta do it late though
my god this is stressful there's a world here there's a
world where's the other crypto wall at least if there's less
fences oh my god imagine if i had your banners this person's
called oh my god if only that would have been so clutch wait
they're resting in front of you they're literally rising in
front of you behind they're literally there look at him
they're rising i gotta ignore that dude this
is crazy where's the other crypto where are the cryptos wait
do you take that e-back in front of you yeah yeah good come
good come yeah i have to keep my flesh health up though oh
my god wait stand on top of them yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey hey hey Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't make your presence now.
Just chill.
Go back up.
Go back up there.
This is the
only...
Oh, my God.
Get an EVEC.
EVEC.
It's not letting me be Valkald.
What the heck?
This is the...
No, what just happened?
What happened?
Wait, what just happened to me?
I just got Kalkalds.
on somebody like somebody was on your head like another guy
was on your head there's no way it was a nade he was a made
it on that game bro you actually got hit on that head what
the fuck there's no way actually got goomba stomped that's
fucking crazy it said i died to a vertnaid but i don't even
think that happened i think i actually somebody somebody's
boxed somebody landed on you and Wait, that is crazy.
Oh my god, you actually got Goomba stomped.
I think I would have, I think I died mid-air as I was going
up to a Burtnade coming down.
Yeah.
That is so unlucky.
That's so rough.
Nice try.
That would have been it.
That would have actually been a crazy, crazy comeback.
The Goomba stomped.
Holy shit.
I saw there was barely any cryptos for how many crypto
players in a game.
Yeah, there was.
that is wild oh my god wait no there is there's two crypto
players and i i swear i only saw two crypto alts in the end
yeah oh well ggs guys ggs ggs ggs i got a great time ggs
i'll see you guys yeah bye oh that's actually crazy i can't
believe he got gloomba stomped i can't
god how how is that possible he somebody was on top of him
and then he died
oh my god how much money did we make i think we made like 1k
more than 1k 1.5k i'm pretty sure i think i made like 1.5k
i'm pretty sure because we had two top fives and that was
like 900 i think i think that was like 900 uh oh wait not
800 sorry did I say 900 $800 and then we get the $500 entry
fee so like when we're in there when you get in you get $500
automatically by just playing and then like all the other
games I think add up would be 1.5 I had a great time it was
fun it was fun I definitely peaked in the beginning um I
definitely uh my uh my gameplay peaked in the beginning and
then it was downhill from there
our placement went downhill from there but we got top five
in two different games we got top five in two games in a row
so it was a fun stream i had a really great time meaning uh
meaning all these people it was fun i had a great time
meaning everybody and um and it was fucking free money we
love free money chat like like we love free money guys and
that's all that matters
that's all that matters i'm gonna make sure if there's
anything else we have to do but i think we're good to go
yeah but yeah thank you everybody i might i'm gonna do a
gorilla stream later on on youtube I'm gonna figure out what
I want to do But I'll be doing another Guerrilla stream
later tonight and just Hang out with all of you guys But
yeah, I hope you guys had a fun time Meeting everybody and
Talking to everyone and Getting to know more from the apex
Scene I had a great time, that was my first time playing
with Jen A great time meeting him And a great time, first
time playing with Timmy And a great time meeting him except
for that one time That I got confused with Sheila
when he kept yelling at me about shields at a great time
though the cue the cue
alright chie-chies everybody chie-chies I am going to I'm
going to call it here as always everybody stay hydrated
posture checked get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it or stay up for a little gorilla's tree I'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys Bye!